alors il ya un petit soucis de connexion
mais on va récupérer le roi est super et
laurent way you lie à alors c'était un
petit soucis de connexion va faire ce
qu'on avait dit qu'on ferait dans ces
cas là ce qu'on va commencer sans la
caméra d'accord sans nommer la mairie on
va aller jouer m que les caméras des
joueurs en fait d'accord je te laisse
couper la mienne à la wii à les couper
en fait de base et en fait on va on va
faire que les on va faire on va faire
que les que les joueurs d'accord ce qui
est pas plus mal d'ailleurs à ça
commençait d'ailleurs alors attends je
vais récupérer les parties et oui ça
commençait donc gré de chou qui surprend
qui joue un match chiant kétou doncker
3g 3g 2 bizarre moi je pensais qu'ils
aiment plutôt se lancer dans un débat
théorique tu vois contre manu ce nom je
veux prendre du coup tu as commenté le
début je vais juste le temps que je
remette à ce que du coup je change de
donc c'est très classique le départ à
saint servais tomavo 4 un peu surprenant
voilà food et 6 donc il veut il veut
retarder que le développement de son
cavalier g8 très probablement pour le
mettre en scène c'est un système assez
souple pour les noirs et ensuite
éventuellement faire c'est ça qui est
cavalier c6 voilà bon ça se joue
c'est intéressant magnus a déjà fait
avec les blancs sont donc guinée connaît
bien les détails de ce genre d'ouverture
et de l'envoi le temps une à 4 59 contre
4,13 pour get choc
donc il connaît mieux je pense les
détails que ghetto on va voir là le coup
normalement c'est d'abord pour essayer
de faire 1,5 à un moment se découvre et
c'est pas mal il appréhender c'est un
cas je pense ou prise en d5 et jouer ces
quatre ans 8 voilà pour attaquer tout de
suite le le centre noir voilà donc là il
va prendre du plomb c'est très
probablement
et voilà et quelque chose va de toute
façon jouer c'est qu'un prochain coup
alors il a fait quoi tu fais un super
boulot hein
désolé de te laisser sa web dont il a
repris il a rappelé du pur rock et au
pied ou la colonne ne peut donner un
échec mais il va faire ses cadres de
toute façon probablement c4eva les
ossètes et au match que je puisse pas
est ce que vraiment je vais pouvoir
montrer les coûts sur le uss et toi tu
le fais ça tu es faire t'inquiète pas
d'accord il ya fait qu'elle est hqe
apprécié de il a fait un mort comme j'ai
dit mais d'abord ils appréhendent et 5k
voyage 4 et rock
il faut qu'ils rentrent le magnus parce
que sinon on voit pas trop ce qui fait
inquiète pas d'ici moins d'une minute
je serai la course ouais d'accord c'est
peu après on est là pendant 3h30 et puis
c'est ce que je dis souvent laurent
c'est qu' il vaut mieux perdre une ou
deux minutes au début a pas commenté
superbe alors le truc bien cadré
casseurs plutôt que de s'embêter pendant
pendant trop laroque donc rock comme
prévu g4 bas il réfléchit peut-être à kg
6 mais ça marche pas du tout il ya 4-5
donc il va faire projet 6 et maintenant
les blancs peuvent faire cas pour
essayer de d'enfermer le fou et qu'une
légère tactique il a fait tout re hui
très malin bien joué j'ai pu mais c'est
le problème
je suis directement sur check point
comme tu suis sûr je suis sur check
point com et je vois les deux joueurs
ouais parce que j'ai fait un petit
décalage du coup par rapport aux coûts
en fait d'accord faut mieux que tu
ailles sur faut mieux taillé sur jazz
comme direct d'accord tu fais comme chef
points comme live tu sais comme quand tu
vas pour jouer le title tous des cons
d'accord donc pour jouer d'accord je
joue plus le title tuesday ya un thé un
type qui s'appelle blue stream
jude et probe et hier joie du côté parti
quoi tu peux plus jouer
ouais si j'ai arrêté je me suis dit
quand même au pain enfin je peux
t'envoyer le lien du coup puisqu'en fait
sinon quand tu dis découragez pas
remarqué mais en fait nous on les voit
enfin
ouais d'accord du coup j'ai l'air
surpris mais ouais déjà les coups alors
atteint ce qui regarde great thou great
food il fait exactement ce dont je te
parlais hier en fait ils attaquent le
roi à fond j'étais sûr qu'il ferait ça
ouais d'accord mais alors comment je
fais pour swiss sign up
ouais mais alors il me reconnais pas en
fait j'ai données collectées avec mon
pseudo c'est ça ouais tu as besoin de
ton pseudo d'accord donc à tanger me
connecter depuis ok désolé non mais
enfin c'est ce que je te dis il vaut
mieux c'est son passé les dix premières
minutes tu as encore trois heures 30
devant toi donc tranquilles ou high
online ensuite j'étais un login et puis
je vais un peu lire le chat aussi
famille l'indycar et 3g 3 celerity exact
donc maintenant fais toi écrite souffre
du coup il a mis le purifient 6 tu vois
ça c'est ce que pour le moment t'as pas
dû voir encore non je vois rien parce
que en fait je cherche je vais changer
de mot de passe
je retrouve plus tu vois ces trucs de de
changer de mot de passe
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai fait ça je
vais en redemander un mets qui mène qui
me renvoie quoi tout enfant votre pauvre
usure lane mais c'est pas c'est pas toi
and are well non moi je suis jeune
ah oui toi c'est la table là je confonds
en fête des grands-mères français à
nawel enfin oui je ne sais pas qui c'est
bon je sais pas qui c'est c'est un grand
maître français une façon comme il est
peut-être annoni on va pas dire son nom
même si on le savait mais
du coup on ne sait pas qui c'est qui est
ce type là normalement j'ai reçu un
email de rappel pour la partie qu'est-ce
qui se passe ben en fait ce qui se passe
pour te faire un topo gris tchouk sa
position elle est complètement
chaotiques je trouve qu'il a aucune
harmonie dans ses pièces mais il un pion
h6 et peut-être un jour il fait de la
musique d'amd qu'adam g 7 matches mais
enfin en gros y'a rien mais c'est son
gameplay n'en fait d'accord donc
attaquer c'est sevelen qui lui a je sais
pas ce qu'il a dit ça parce que j'ai pas
parlé à blannaves en avant mais comme
vlad m'avait dit si un jour comme je
disais hier si tu joues contre carlson
dans ta vie le seul chance de faire quoi
que ce soit contre ce mec là c'est
d'attaquer son roi j'imagine qu'il a
donné le même conseil a great choc après
j'en sais rien tu vois ouais je pense
que je pense que par exemple
bon après ok peut-être un peu plus fort
que moi mais que faire ouais on a vu
hier il s'est fait ouais cette partie où
finalement c'était pas facile pour moi
donc voilà c'est bon alors en direct
on est bien chez steevy non donc je vais
sur live tu vas sur live et et après on
va à droite normalement tu peux chercher
des joueurs et tu vas trouver magnus et
on est bon ouais d'accord en plus libye
mais montrer en fait il y envoyer des
fichiers pendant le championnat d'europe
par équipes où le fichier s'appelait
l'informatique pour les nuls pour un
capitaine qui est censé mettre les
joueurs en confiance
ouais je me demande tu vois mais il n'a
pas complètement tort
en direct alors joueur non à droite toi
tu dois trouver des joueurs tu vas voir
un petit podium avec les joueurs
meilleurs joueurs et magnus carlsen
juste numéro un donc je vais jouer tu
étais sûr là c'est sur la plage au delà
ouais t'es sûr tu es comme live ouais
ben en bas à droite tu dois avoir un
petit podium avec
ou tu peux cliquer pour trouver les
joueurs en fait je me ridiculise
c'est l'histoire de ma vie ce genre de
truc un peu tu vois c'est juste c'est
non pas du tout je ne trouve pas
recherché recherché recherché magnus
carlsen oui voilà c'est fait comme ça
wisques harcèle un sujet non pas du tout
ok mais je suis un ténor récupère le
lien que je t'envoie cliquer directement
dessus on est sûr que tu sois sur la
place donne sur sur skype vraiment
désolé non mais t'inquiète pas on est
tranquille ou alors là ça me louvre dans
le 6/9 à mince ça t'ouvre parents
connectés là on çà me voir non mais là
c'est bon ça nous sur internet explorer
j'utilise pas foutu faire un copier
coller du rl en fait est sûr c'est
effectivement alors la diète en copine
de façon tu tu me lira jamais autant que
les gens quand on organise un tournoi le
tournoi bitstream toutes les semaines à
chaque fois qu'on le fait il ya des
dizaines de personnes qui nous disent
comment s'inscrire ouais mais c'est
sensé nord mais en fait je vois pas bien
sûr j'ai joué propose de jouer mais
c'est parce qu'ils me sinon j ouer non
alors vas-y atteint je vois que je vois
pas un truc en bas à droite je n'ai pas
tant mais tu ta des partitas un
échiquier quand même à gauche je vois le
way j'allais chez keeway en plein milieu
alors eh ben
1 en fait je surfais tatata trois castes
à un grand échiquier à gauche au milieu
tard à droite un espèce de truc avec
jouer partie tournois auront à droite
est en fait en bas à droite ta ta ta ta
une petite bulle de conversations tu as
des petites jumelles tu avec ben en fait
faut que tu ailles verte à un petit
podium en fait
eyes est en fait car c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon
et là tu fais suite et c'est la deuxième
donc il a gagné la première manche il a
gagné la première est bon bah j'aime on
est parti d'accord on pourra peut-être
la revoir alors là c'est il voulait
faire un hérisson mais il y aura pas d
eau ils sont assez ma partie des quatre
dessins c'est la partie à barcelone
d'interdire ont donc je connais très
bien voilà il va faire tous les sacs
c'est la partie compris que rien a
dernièrement il a joué le foot est si
sûre lieu de comprendre et 2 et pour
répondre à la question ne cherchez pas
préparé le match pour magnus mais il se
trouve que cette position ans précise
j'ai déjà regardé pour magnus
donc il prend le truc très au sérieux
doit donc ça ça c'est un signe qu'ils y
que magnus francs la compétition
sérieuse c'est ce que tu es en train de
nous dire ah c'est pas au style parce
que c'est un truc que tu vois que j'ai
regardé quoi sur pied en france et 6 il
ya eu 4 et surtout prend ces six joueurs
comme pierre celsis il ya eu 4 et les
blancs les blancs sont un peu mieux tu
fais hélas le meilleur coup le meilleur
coup c'est de donner un pion et où j'ai
déjà de donner un pion tu vois ça sert
que c'est quand même une grosse prépare
parce que si on est quand même au
douzième coup qui te sort 4 et que tu
lui dis que les pierres avantage blanc
ça veut dire que les gars ce que toi
tempo donc tu vois et ouais c'est pas
c'est pas une variante hypertendus tu
vois c'est quand même une anglaise
symétrique ou ouais ouais mais quand
même voix les noms il prend le match
très au sérieux
je veux un truc comme ça on dit tu vois
après les gens les regarde pas trop les
parties de beats tu vois donc tu peux tu
peut mixer en fait tu peux mixé entre
prépa est pas prêt pas parce que les
gens sont des gens savent pas quoi mais
j'ai eu en fait ça et là des gens tu as
qui parle du speech est c'est qu'ils
disent oui mais le speech est c'est une
compétition se mit à me caler tout ça
mais
pression plus je vois deux matches plus
je vois deux nouveautés que face et
comme quasiment comme un championnat de
blitz en réel en fait j'aime sans que
les joueurs ne prennent autant au
sérieux
ouais mais c'est ce que je t'ai dit hier
un magnus il n'aime pas perdre que ça
soit en vite sans pull est en baskets ou
à n'importe quoi tu vois donc là il sait
que ça va être tendu donc ils essayent
ces cas tu vois l'autre lui je voyais a
pas commencé à faire n'importe quoi
donc il joue plus ou moins une petite
idée qu'on avait en fait c'est ça c'est
ça casse pas des briques non plus hein
oui je me doute bien c'est pas la
nouveauté que tu dises ait pas la
serviette pâle anglaise mais bon petite
idée qui a été jouée en fait jusqu'à fou
17 petit rock food et 6 tu vois où 10e
coup c'était la partie vidéo anhorn delà
de san luis
donc voila c'était largement largement
inspiré de cette partie dans ce voyage
pas comme entrée nouveau concept donc là
il ya le choix est le bon a priori je
jouais dam des quatre essais pour
doubler les pions c'est quand même si
c'est avant une finale quand même assez
confortable donc tu veux jouer d'harry
des quatre comme ça tu mets tu cloud
lecavalier 6 tu le prends au prochain et
tu forcera les noirs à faire dame prend
qui on prend je vais montrer à l'écran
t'inquiète pas reconduit les lignes jeu
bon je fais un coup lambda genre on va
faire un coup n'importe quoi fera f6
d'un premier fils et donc tu veux jouer
cette finale contre le curé isolé des 5
voilà et le meut le chou qui est pas qui
est pas idéal mais là il y va tendre
l'autre a fait tour s'est vite donc
cavalier ou cinq fois ces logis il peut
pas trop les en v5 parce que je il y
aurait des kg 4 tu vois donc il fait
faut six briques aussi comme ça il faut
continuer à construire la case g4 et
empêche de de martyriser le cavalier
mais ça ça doit se tenir non pour pour
les noirs avec un jeu correct ouais ça
doit se tenir mais je vois un petit coup
de tourbe et 6 elle va pas être drôle
hein allez pas marrante à jouer voici
déjà tu me fais ça je te fais casser si
ce site ait changé d'âme je vais faire
plus on prend je vais menacé cavaliers
de cet échec chemin ce pion à 5
c'est très désagréable pour les uns mais
bon il
il a du temps donc il peut il peut à
tenir par la great food qui fait déjà
lié à 3 minutes se dit j'ai une éternité
jeu
c'est comme c'est comme des partis donc
on est au 20e il reste trois minutes ça
va bien ah oui et bien la position doit
pas l'accusé lorsqu'il répétera pas tu
vois ça ou alors il jouera
il rentre dans ce dont tu parles et donc
tu penses cali ces six là pour voir ça
sur pastore c6 parce que quand même ça
ait changé d'âme un hors jeu peu fils un
pion quoi c'est pas de jouer quatre
cépages ou et sa menace f5
il veut jouer sur le clouage assez joli
c'est très joli et sur des f 5 je te
faire j'ai quatre la buba je n'ai pas
fait au premier coup mais quand même
quoi
ouais tu as quand même vingt et un coups
de retard mais tt mais tu prends un coup
tu vois un coup ici pour les noirs
manger j'en vois pas trop la revue
théorie puisque damev 5g et qu'adam e4
f5 et le fou est enfermé ouais donc
peut-être g6 obligé alors j'ai tissé
c'est moche j'ai six mois tu as
peut-être des tactiques
j'ai pas vrai bon pour le moment il ya
peut-être rien qui marche mais tu sens
que si tu fais g65 insurgés 6,6 m
peut-être g4 surgissent ici a fait
tomber 8 et encore il est bon il faut
suivre la tour wpt est exactement le
genre si en place f 5 1 pour montrer
comme ça on fait tout reprend b6 et m et
surtout reprend b si ça et puis on prend
aussi ce pour recréer la menace double
attaque mur adam prosys hockey solide
pour le moment grille tout cas elles
n'ont jamais dit accent du sud ouest
super merci je prends comme un
compliment c'est pas comme si tu étais
du sud ouest en même temps ouais ouais
j'ai pensé l'avoir perdu tu vois mais
non donc il fait tourner leur médaille à
+25 mégarde la colonne ouais mais ça
fait bien peu du coup en leroy gyan
peut-être un peu faible et or elle va
peut-être avoir un petit con tre jeu
avec des idées de paix rhdp tenant pour
défendre
ouais d'un match 4 on peut envisager de
mach 4 tu vois derrière cinq mois
maintenant j'ai quatre a moins envie de
faire un petit coup de hache 3 d'abord
on ya peut-être faire du dam ces deux
fois f5 fougue quatre trucs comme ça non
voilà bien vu je te dis on peut avoir
notre no 10 minutes
ouais de folie on devine toulouse ouais
ça nan mais ça arrive en tête
et puis si paix à la norme et grosse
défense de grisou qu'un énorme en
défense
et pour vraiment pas évident tu vois
après moi je commençais déjà à déprimer
à fait apte à jouer pas tomber beach et
je suis pas sûr que j'aurais dû jouer ce
rôle c'était c'était beau c'était bien
joué et là maintenant et vous tapiez c6
donc ouais pour empêcher 5 phu cat way
et on de fougères fou prend f3 et tour
de 8,1 ça marche pas il y aura cavaliers
je voulais faut sacrifier faire mater
trop c'est trop vite d'abord tu vois bah
oui mais ce que c'est autant dans
l'esprit que tu vois à tulle où tu
demeures ouais non voilée dans mes tours
8 salaire bien oui sans livrer tour 8 ça
me plaît à la tour elle joue pas donc il
ya un moment il faut il faut moi je pars
et surtout huit ici d'ailleurs fabien
qui est en train de jouer au jeu des
paris c'est sûr tu as points comme dans
un jeu de promenade big rich la gagner
pendant un match
près de 13 ans et il y avait aussi il ya
aussi plus en a deux qui traîne un
magnus lci s'est envolé que sa tour en b
si ça fait plus rien j'aime pas du tout
ce qu'il a fait bon c'est bien pour le
suspense oui là peut-être fois être 5
maintenant ah non il y aura prise tout
rien il ya peut-être pas grand-chose
ouais méprise d'apprendre qu'ils voient
enfin si toi tu prends à 2 et tu files
avec le pion à têtu fait sa renommée
dame prado y avait cinq potes et amis à
5 y aurait non il y aura f53 est
embêtant ouais
et si je fais tous ces huit cavaliers
français 8 et tours 2 ouais
effectivement mais tout s'est vite tu
sais on n'est pas en jouant aux dames
donc je suis pas obligée de prendre donc
je peux faire tous ces sept
oui mais du coup ça veut dire que je
peux faire dame prend à de f5 est fou
c'est 8 pts et fruits yahia il ya ton
front s'est vite qui traîne je pense oui
mais moi je sais pas pas mal ouais c'est
pas mal et le jean ce genre d'idées
peuvent pas marcher fff 5
mais non ça ressemble à une proposition
à nom marque qui va être moins bien il
va peut-être
tourner un échec dame prend f5 et après
ils te vi ouais il te vis d'ajoie f4
vois tu as envie que s'ils purent ita l2
ça serait égal mais la culture à 10,4
c'est toujours toujours très compliqué
yahia a fait vraiment une très bonne
défense c'est très impressionnant
bon maintenant magnus il peut calculer
aussi qu'il prend des 5
tu vois menaces plus ou moins des
cavaliers m6 avec pour preuve cette
blessure qui avait duré roigé six états
plus d'échecs
ouais y voyager voilà maintenant il est
en indoor mode in est en mode j'essaie
de dire emmanuel magne the irish utile
en mode push et 30 secondes je suis
beaucoup trop bien autant dans cette
partie qui jouait beaucoup trop vite
j'aurais dû réfléchir un peu plus mais
n'y a pas juste pour prendre des 5 avec
l'idée d'amener 3 après pourrait changer
mais yahia d'amsterdam à detroit il y
aurait tout ranger deux échecs et chaud
il veut placer du damev 5 arrive à
sentir et il va s'en tirer magnifique
bon nul et intérêts il a proposé
mühleberg accepter mes belles parties
d'oran excellent excellente avec une
excellente prépa et et une énorme
défense de degré de cheveux alors oui on
voit à va nous faire un grand vide à la
carcel ah non non dragons
il a vu le livre de mathieu cornette ce
conflit drago dîner très content ouais
nan futur de la fée pour les copains
ouais je vais acheter il est très bien
mais c'est vraiment agréable à lire et
le travail est très bien fait enfin qui
cachent pas des idées tu vois où il a
fait vraiment un truc connaître c'est
une belle pub que tu fais au bouquin de
de mathieu
ouais mais mathieu mathieu fait des
meilleurs tu vois préparateur français
et il est toujours très sérieux toujours
très bien préparé c'est toujours très
compliqué d'ailleurs de vêtements de
nuit le choisir l'ouverture et donc
voilà la clé de son travail
alors là c'est in vienna un peu bizarre
avec sur quatre bessin
magnus à leur savoir ce qu'il fait une
fois de plus un aspect chaud non mais
j'ai l'impression qu'ils te sortent les
deux des prépas de partout en fait j'ai
l'impression qu'il sait la guerre elle
ajoute je pense qu'en bullet ça va
mollir mais là là ça ça joue très
sérieusement ça envoie du pâté jusqu'à
maintenant
ouais donc petit rock a priori parce
qu'elle y aille à damas quatre échecs
qui menacent tu vois donc bon on aime et
on prend 1,7 sur tire aucun tout
simplement
et puis le pion n'est pas facile je fais
tout reprendre si on prend à 7 et bon
courage à une deuxième d'un ça serait
quand même ça serait embêtant
après treize coups j'ai pas pensé à ça
qu'est-ce qu'il est là donc je prends
ces quatre maintenant on attend et il
peut pas ouais bien vu vous prend ses 4
et là je suppose rock
ouais ok on essayait de gratter le pion
des six ans joue un cahier 17 tombes et
8 voit obligé parce que mes études est
ce que tu peux essayer de faire du tour
des huit pourtant prendre cali des
quatre où ça va être trop dangereux tu
peux tu peux tu peux c'est à calculer tu
vois c'est une position où je peux pas
te dire tu vois il faut il faut sortir
ces pièces tu vois c'est très concret c
est un pur en v6 mais potentiellement
les noircir prenait plus investis soit
ils ont la paire de fou et apure 4 qui
est un peu faible
il ya le jouet ou encore le centre plein
et pas stable les noirs peuvent être
mieux mais ils peuvent aussi être
perdants en gros soit ils sont mieux
soit ils sont perdants soit c'est égal
non égalée galles ça existe pas trop ce
genre de position et ce quoi est-ce
qu'on peut santé cavaliers b5 peut-être
mon premier vrai en skaï c7 c'est pas
mal quand tu vois qui est db5 je vais te
faire x 6 je suppose je sais pas voilée
c'est déjà un poids 6 peut-être non
je sais pas tout va dire c'est trop
compliqué pour moi je te fais qu'aller
17 voix laroquais trop compliqué voilà
il faut calculer quelle et 17 sur calais
17 qui accueillent ces six voix voilée
qui menacera cac et prend b4 et qui a
été sept îles et celles ci sont hélas
qui prend des 4 et le truc est cloué
voilà quelle est cette fois avec hey mec
c'est aussi ce qu'avait prometis protège
à tour ouais mais peut-être je peux
prendre tu prends je prends à 8 way
du coup c'est égal ça ça c'est tu vois
c'est le cas où c'est pas tout à fait
égal talent pur v2 qui est faible le
foot cases blanches qui est pas terrible
geste fait refouler cette je pense pas
et north un peu mieux mais bon ça se bat
quoi eh ouais et il ya tour des huit
évidemment qu'ils se regardent autour
des 8 par exemple je te peu ce que je
peux te faire peut-être de 5
si tu fait d'apprendre 5 20 m 3 c'est
pareil les trucs tu es avec oscar mais
fera bien vu lors on avec la tour en a
huit qui restent qui reste en prise
jolie ou alors au cinq dames f4 je sais
pas franchement c'est une position même
en partie donc tu vois tu dois passer un
quart d'heure
oui mais au sein d'un f4 à tour sera
plus protégé en des 8es peut-être on
pourra faire du cavalier prend aussi
sous je ne sais quoi avec ça va être
bien franc suisse mme
non mais c'est un bordel sans nom je
propose qu'on fasse nul on passe à la
suivante c'est trop compliqué non mais
enfin c mais même en partie longue moi
je me noie la dent fin je ne vois plus
rien que je refuse de jouer
ouais ouais c'est vrai que bon il a pas
il n'y a pas 50 options je vois pas ce
qu'il va faire un parc à es17 autour des
huîtres ou blaise est éventuellement
mais quand même ça urge de robes de
reprendre ce pion tu vois mais ça ça se
peut que les blancs soit gagnant en fait
ici parce que si t'as pas de bonnes
manières de récupération v6 était juste
très très mal ouais mais quelle est
cette je vois pas ce qu'il ya à quai 17
cavaliers à quatre peut-être en tout cas
sur la caméra il fait moins le malin que
contre soi je peux te dire que c'est pas
la même taille mais là c'est l'autre
c'est un autre niveau et il le sait très
bien ce à shine respect pour sage mais
sacha aussi là il a le regard noir du
rose cost a l'impression que si là ils
sont les deux ils sont chauds quoi c
hélas non c'est la guerre c'est cool en
plus ils sont chauds de san luis tu vois
où ils ont quand même joué des rapides
et des blitz
donc tu vois ils sont en forme ils sont
sûrs a lancé ils ont envie de gagner et
un truc de prestige à fait fou prend ces
trois donc il devait pas aimé il devait
pas aimer les autres options
ouais mais sur coup franc et pmi qui est
des sept cavaliers à 4 et là peut-être
qu'ils récupèrent le pion ouais mais il
viendra du dan des trois-tours fb un nom
mais la dame b3 je te fais tomber vite
ouais c'est vrai que tu le gagnes mais
tu fais ton prend 1,5
tu vois mais ok j'ai besoin de moi mais
c'est pas dramatique par les fautes
il ya aussi cavaliers pro us is bessette
et dame prend 17 à calcul est exact
bien vu partout à et je suis chaud des
fois tactique et qu'il prend 2,6 c'est
pas mal du tout d'ailleurs qu'il est
pour ainsi dire pas se faire choper un k
way mais quelquefois aussi c'est le seul
coup sûr tu vois un tel coup sûr où tu
étais sûr d'arriver en finale avec un
tour de plus il n'ya pas tu laisses le
pion à vivant pour les noirs ça toujours
être un bon contrôle
bon enfin c'est sûr que c'est un
avantage mais c'est loin d'être sûr que
tu sois gagnant après qu'elle ait
produit 6 ouais ouais je suis d'accord
c'est même à peu près sûr que non tweet
tous locaux moins que tout soit elle un
jour à l'ap le tu vas y vas relate et
progressiste
donc voilà il ya cavaliers au 5 mai
qu'elle ne serait pas l'air de trop
marché à cause de quel point final à un
peu par le nord et si on pouvait pas
introduire d'anne decis avants 17 mai
ils rendent dans ce truc là mais tu es
tu veux faire fou prend tu sais jouer
sur le roi garde et des pièces d'amd 6
au pire je préfère je peux claqué en v6
et dames français non mais là ça va être
nul mais il perd près selon de très bons
mais dans les matches comme ça il ya
aussi tu sais l'impact psychologique si
tu fais défends tu fais défendre comme
c'est non c'est pas mal mais là il avait
attrapé dans l'ouverture en légende
si tu vois assez vite ça ressemble à une
prépa quand même donc donc c'est juste
que magnus il va pas il va pas répéter
cette ouverture
non mais je pense que c'est ce que je
t'ai dit hier je pense qu'il va un peu
tout essayé ma mieux et que je connais
et je pense que le répertoire de ketchup
sera nettement plus stable
on verra on verra si ma prédiction et je
pense qu'il va essayer même sur des cas
tu vois il va essayer des ragots zine
des envies dame normaux peut-être
longueur mid america 6 ont peut-être des
griffes elle qu'est ce que j'en sais
avec les blancs ou s'il va essayer un
peu tous les coups et voir et voir ce
qui lui plaît et se poser se poser là où
ça lui plaît
c'est donc tu penses que ça oui ça
normalement la position a pas été
terrible il va pas à ça près des six
moins que tu vois moi étaient quelques
uns à côtés qui te disent avec un ordi
qui te brief entre deux parties mais tu
vois ça serait pas ça serait pas
productif au trader s'est autorisé un
mais vlad m'a dit qu'il le faisait pas
c'est autorisé il aurait eu droit
pendant le break de ce fait à brive mais
ça joue tellement peu que ils vont pas
voir mais v'là de maddie ce genre c'est
des matches qui sont tellement fatiguant
que ces regards il est peut-être en
train de l'attraper avec l'idée qu'il
aura poussé deux échecs
si jamais tu fais à quatre fous prend
1,4 tout raciste pour clouer y aurait dû
y aurait eu le petit échec quoi mais bon
oui comme je t'ai dit hier pendant la
finale comme nakamura endettée au
dernier stage avoir le vent en
championnat du monde et on était la
pièce à côté avec avec peter mais bon tu
vois bertrand l'a pas on l'a pas dérangé
pendant le match stressant se passer
tellement bien qu'ils aient pas besoin
mais de toute façon ça c'était le plan
tu vois de pas non mais en fait tu peux
rien faire puisque comme nous y
fabriquons avec l'appareil va très bien
je vois enfin b6 ouais ok ça peut
checker mais aussi non mais c'est
tellement fatigant et en plus quand tu
arrives à +17 eu tellement plus sur
l'ouverture qui viennent on l'a en fait
c'est que le moment où tu peut coacher
séance est avant de 3 + 2 est déjà bon
mais après avant le impuissante face à
rien ouais donc là ouais c'est archi nul
1 c33 compte de bon il va il va essayer
mais
il a eu plus de chance les héros est
vraiment zéro il n'y a pas de dégâts pas
de risques ça c'est un gagnant niveau la
comète entourant le 4 mai maniez sommet
des tours en c2 enfin la tour sur la
seconde quand il va même d'attendre le
cas après d'équipé hk a three bo3 c'est
vraiment c'est pas ça toi laurent tu
annules ça contre n'importe qui
facilement avec les noirs pareil
normalement je pense que oui mais oui
ouais tu voi ip comme moi il va sur la
seconde il manquera pas ce que c'est pas
ce qui nous inquiète justement peut-être
droit h3 et sur pions proches se fait
tour à tour car je te récupère le curage
4 et j'ai un peu amélioré ma sauf un crs
tenu à améliorer la structure
c'est toujours insidieux mais c'est vrai
que ce n'est pas ce n'est pas optimale à
ce qu'il a fait maintenant il doit de
faire surtout aussi 6-7 et quand même
beaucoup plus simple parce que là il va
prend h 4 leroy marie van asch 5 et 6
mai sans plus mais voilà c'est bizarre
qu'on va la défendre et ben non mais ça
doit rester nul est quand même c'est
rare de voir magnus oui non là il s ils
pensaient que il a lui proposé ne le
sait pas je sais pas ce qui lui a pris
enfin met d'ailleurs autre truc
autre truc discute avec vlad aussi c'est
que il me disait que great chouk c'était
peut-être le seul joueur au monde qui
était pas moins fort que magnus en
finale deux tours pas dans toutes les
finales en finale deux tours exact
précisément je sais pas et donc utiliser
que enfin pas en parlant de ce match on
parle en général tu sais des joueurs
dans la chair des points forts et des
points faibles et il me disait c'est un
des trucs sein des sols à papa papa être
moins fort que j'ai l'impression que
très honnêtement tu vois c'est le
premier être la première chose négative
que je vais dire sur magnus était
peut-être la dernière aussi c'est que en
fait il est très très fort dans les
filiales de tours il est un peu mieux tu
vois pour poser problème mais quand il a
en défense et il a une petite tendance à
se relâcher
j'ai remarqué ça plusieurs fois et a
laissé des chances tu vois là et ça doit
pas exister ce truc ggr contre h oui oui
tu devrais jamais trouvé que j'ai donc
voilà il peut il
mais par contre je pense que quand il a
un petit avantage dans ce genre de final
un pion de plus c'est comme ça qu'il a
gagné le premier match contre un homme
tu vois 5 et 6 où il en fait il ya deux
finales de tournoi il lui pose des
problèmes jusqu'au bout quoi en fait il
ne l'ès pas tu vois là sinon c'est
hallucinant file et le côté pratique tu
vois c'est incroyable
toujours le coup le plus embêtant et a
fait un dandy craquer quoi du coup un
peu comme capable en cas qui étaient un
peu la réputation être un peu pareil
ouais voilà exactement genre très bon
final mais surtout quand tu es mieux
mais les baskets se prendre un tour à ge
ses sages et si les défend moins bien
que moi tu vois comme tu as dit au début
du stream bon c'est quand même c'est pas
très bon signe pour les toits mais il a
de la chance que ce qui reste la fin de
la chance c'est pas de la chance mais le
fait qu'il reste le pion g après ça fait
que tu peux faire la défense passive
terre infinie d'or en plus ouais bon
fils d'or ça va c'est dans ses cordes
aussi nommé j'apparaisse il se retrouve
avec le roi de la passe devant je sais
pas quoi tu as même fin la défense
passive suffit à yoff hashtag c'est joli
donc la cellule tout de suite
roy price tag ton prince tient bon ici
poser des problèmes pour pas grand chose
mais ça va c'était toujours dans l'ordre
du canada
ça peut laisser des bons dans un match
on tue circonvenir enfin ça peut se
payer plus tard cette erreur là est
peut-être pas j'essaye de rêver tu vois
je suis mené d'un point je suis moins
bon en bullet laisse-moi réveil du coup
du coup il change plus du coup parce
qu'il était bien dans la partie
précédente tu vois après l'ouverture
il revient sur les traces du crime voilà
il va lui faire payer ses trois lâchers
poste où il va changer il réfléchit
3 quand même ou 5 et donc il veut voir
là non bon on va voir on va voir ce qui
va qui va montrer magnus donc là il
gagna ouais y'a deux coups bon je
connais un peu ça aussi c'est un truc
pas très joué ça bon qui peut qui peut
être essayer tu vois pour une ou deux
parties ça a été jouée par dubaï et dont
il est sûr qu'à y penser 3-2 fait
dépenser 3 et tu joues la finale qui est
pas qui est qui et pas si clair il a
fait cas c'est celle qui est aussi un
coût possible
et là normalement les blancs en fait ils
jouent ils jouent b3 foulée deux dames
c'est 2 3 c1 pour fdf et essayer de
pousser des cas dans des bonnes
conditions est ce que tu peux faire le
dante inde amma derrière tu peux le
faire tu vois mais je vais essayer quand
même de jouer un moment aux cavaliers
leucate et des cartes voix il fait
tourner en direct à trois doigts tu vois
il fait parce que je dis moi je pensais
plutôt des trois tubes et deux on avait
regardé ça aussi un peu donc vraiment un
match très sérieux au niveau des
ouvertures des deux côtés non mais c'est
quelque chose quoi c'est cool
ouais ça dépend pour qui tu vois moi je
suis un peu les toits qui joue là
maintenant donc ouais j'avais bossé ça
je pensais qu'il y avait joué en finale
du championnat du monde mais en fait non
seulement la classe finalement il peut
jouer au rugby sur chaque point comme
bon on va pas non mais on est quand même
le plan mais il a eu peur
kébé cap tu vois mais je sais pas mais
peut-être que et cavaliers à cinq là
c'est pas un coup bah ouais ou tu fais
bk je suis fait four b3 jetant fils 6e
para est sûr qu'à cinq oui mais c'est
pour ça qu'il faut pas faire il fallait
pas faire apprendre parce que yahia kébé
cas c'était pas les dames b1 et après tu
la meilleure car la 5ème juste du
matériel cavalia 5 à larguer du matériel
oui je vois pas comme défense je sais
qu'un seul coup
je prends ces 4 comprend ces cas ce
fonds prend ses 4es procès mais tf6 toi
mais je compte vraiment retrouver le
fait qu'alassane attends je vais
vérifier puisque je peux mettre
l'ordinateur
ouais mais il ya les cavaliers 5 c'était
bon c'est sûr c'était bon mais comment
ils peuvent rater des trucs pareils
la nati quand on leur dit jouer fou fou
c quatre et dix et qui défend des ouais
mais qu'elle prend ses quatre français 4
m6 était content tu vois tu as les deux
fous c'est sûr ce n'est pas moins bien
oui mais s'ils voient qu'il ya cinq
jours quoi tu vois c'est bizarre il
réfléchit pas où j'ai passé bizarrement
ça arrive tu sais quand tu as des
cadeaux comme ça auquel tu t'attends pas
parfois tu les prends quoi non mais
quelle approche huit mois je jouerai ici
cavaliers ou 4 suite des quatre voies
qui relie au cap c'est ce qui est bien
c'est que tata que tata que 5 et
cavaliers ou katia peut-être f5 bien non
et puis après je peux t'en cher et que 4
ou pas ouais d'ailleurs ou pas houphouët
6 annonce aussi sur les pions non mais
quel est le cap c'est pas mal france
c'est hyper compliqué ces milieux jeu
jamais réussi à bien les jouer ni avec
une couleur avec les pires que ça se
joue il faut que j'arrive à faire des
cadres d'un bonnes conditions si
j'allais faire des cadres dans de bonnes
conditions je vais être bien si j'y
arrive pas je vais être moins bien est
ce qu'avec les noirs un plan jordanie 8
f5 d'un match 5 tu vois un peu dans
l'esprit
c'est ça peut être un truc ça peut être
un truc médaille le fou en b2 tu vois tu
n'as pas envie en général pas plutôt en
mode web 6 enfin moi ce que je dis ça se
trouve au prochain coup f5 tu vois mais
j'aurai en tout cas plutôt envie de
jouer six ans la série sont tu fais
plutôt f6 et attend voir parce que
l'assemblée des quatre maintenant ils
vont ils vont marcher plus souvent hk
alors là alors là c'est ouais bon c'est
énorme h4 écoute
bon vous prend
sérieux là sargeras ça me dépasse alors
je suis d'accord je sais pas c'est de
faire qu'avec il veut faire qu'à
l'étranger 3g deux tours h11 quelque
chose comme ça je sais pas ou alors on
prend h quatre cavaliers ou 4 je sais
pas honnêtement je jeu a peut-être fou
prend h4 alors je te fais fou prend
ainsi skype réussissent et j'ai trois
rois g2 ça pas l'air terrible
franchement j'ai pas on va te faire g6
fou j'ai sept on va se cache un oui ça
paraît pas ça ne paraît pas ou quoi bon
jécistes humour un peu la grande
diagonale mais il faut un f6 quand je
fais ça je jeu récurrent et 6 quand tu
fais g3 et je couvre qua non mais enfin
tu sais que je suis fan de ce genre de
coups mais f6 tu ne s'en cache pas et si
si si ils bougent pas sacha puisse
maintenant rouge et quatre bombes et il
va faire ni sort tant qu'on y est
mehdi sors de ce corps sans blâmer dit
ouais c'est vrai voyage qui savent asie
pour un cours petit bonhomme
en fait on vous a menti c'est mehdi avec
les blancs c'est un match c'est mehdi
contre saimone williams en fait ce match
5 h 15 à moins de moyens c'est pour les
cons qui regarde ma chance qu'il fait la
vie tempo farrell vertus prend le pion
il est très heureux j'ai ouvert ma
colonne h
enfin se finit quoi ouais donc là il a
fait d'amener s'élever du coup ce
sacrifice de piau il est pas si mal
maintenant
non c'est ça casse pas le jeu trouve pas
ça extraordinaire en plus on n'a rien
compris c'est le mot what the fuck you
choix les verts qui sont aux
commentaires les mecs ne comprennent
absolument rien à ce qui se passe bon
bah hk tu donnes un pion coup je ne le
prends pas bon tu comprends maintenant
pourquoi il fallait on s'est mis à jouer
des grob et à faire n'importe quoi
j'avance de regarder des matches comme
ça où nous vivons bas ok quoi ouais
d'accord je le vois le oui je comprends
le concept mais en fait on peut pas
faire la guerre à vichy mais veut y
mettre aussi
si tu fais genre cavaliers prend fou
prend acte en profite pour placer la
tourangelle imite c'est pas intéressant
ce truc ouais je sais c'est un bon deal
quoi je fais attention à une tactique il
faut être cavaliers prochain si on prend
1,5 et maintenant
vous pensez six dames province inquiète
à plus de oui tu as oui tu pourrais plus
couvrir ça pourrait marcher ce genre de
trucs oui bon après si tu prends de la
tour machin tu sauves encore bien on va
alors justement je te fait qu'elle prend
le 5 comprend le sac il faut prendre sa
cachette et la sucette et c'est pas
terrible à la saq writer elle fut g4 qui
restera peut-être en prise qu'avec part
et dans l'esprit en tout cas pour que
les pourvois ça peut être une technique
en fait moi je te vois pas c'est normal
oui c'est normal je te vois pas d'accord
en fait on ne se voit pas en fait se
voit pas d'accord non mais j'ai mis que
les joueurs parce que c'est en fait
s'ils continuent mais les joueurs en
caméra les machins ça fait énormément de
caméras et le flux internet des fois
yves daccord
donc je me dis que dans une compétition
c'est quand même plus intéressant tu vas
en fait on a le choix entre nous les
joueurs
je me dis les joueurs c'est quand même
qui remue non mais je vois pas quand
j'ai les pieds sales chez c'est normal
aussi ouais donc ça ça me perturbe et un
petit peu mais bon très bien mais en
tout cas tout ce que tu dis j'essaye de
montrer enfin qui a trahi et voilà
maintenant qu'ils ont prendre qui
perlent il perdure mais trois maintenant
et le prend du coup tourer attendent
matériel on en est où
condamné à deux points de plus pour les
noirs mais le pion en haïti ce qui est
quand même pas qu'ils doublent et kepa
tail et le purifient ce qui casse pas
des briques non plus au final
ouais mais en fait ça va refaire qu'il
soit là non les noirs sont mieux vaut
clairement la cccc clairement ça pas du
tout marché sans impact voit son âge 4h
5h si cela fait que ce n'était pas
extraordinaire je pense qu'ils savaient
plus trop laisser de faire marcher
cavaliers ou 4 et des quatre îles a pas
réussi y a pas voulu attendre
il s'est dit ben bostrom vivent en blitz
ça se défend là il pas facile à défendre
cette position parce que tu auras envie
de faire un coup de fouet à kiev 6 en
fait mais comment tu fais peut-être
caral des deux caves à leucate idée de
fou dessin je pensais à dessein jolly on
est cinq pour d'air
est fou croire f3 pour prendre et si
c'est maintenant je t'attaque le fouest
roi et le pion réussissent à tanger en
train de bouger les pièces pour montrer
oui et tu attaques tout en fait oui joli
mais j'attaque tout joli très joli mais
encore une fois il est pas obligée de
prendre
non mais ça c'est des règles qu'il
faudrait changer tu vois aux échecs par
un pion aux prix là je suis obligé de
ranger s'il n'a pas le droit révèle you
soon hwi après ouais mais il veut le
reprendre à quoi que donc il va faire la
foux prend option prend pas ça va
changer donc commencé plus fort c'est
quoi tu comprends il peut te laisser le
pion en vif au bras à la 12e' la qualité
un très joli et avec des chèques étaient
ici c'est très dur messieurs mais le
clan des cèpes et quand même très fort
ah c'est le beau jeu ça c'est de la
loterie d'un n'était pas très sympa
quand même
ou bien soit pascal et les pions passé
tu vois le pion patience et cinq bien
protégé une belle majorité albert donc
un bon avantage
bon là à priori ils menacent tour trois
tours j'ai 3 tu vois le royal avec tours
j'ai sept tours 7
mais est ce que les blancs peuvent être
carrément mieux ici laurent et c'est
possible parce que le x 1,5 et un
monstre et le purin des six est aussi un
monstre
ouais c'était c'était vraiment très bien
joué de la part de madness la mare en
plus gris tout cas peu de temps pour
défendre cette finale qui est pas
évidente à c'est vrai qu'il ya cette
seconde manche très importante contre
nîmes 15 pouces et 6 elle va empêcher
ces quartiers où les cinq sur ces 4
maintenant il faut qu'il y ait un nato
être trois fosses is ok bon lait des
noirs ont stabilisé maintenant il sait
encore très bien défendu une chose pour
les narines l'achète pour les saracens
qui dans d'anciennes pour l'enjeu 10 et
les défenses qui tiennent le ouais parce
que j'ai pas girex et c'est pas loin de
s'être segatwa parce que vous êtes
comment tu vas tu vas tu vas améliorer
la position noir j'en suis le maître la
marche avant avec c
4 ouais voilà ouais mais tu mets la
marche avant pour un coup oui tu avances
pas plus loin c'est un jeu c'est un peu
comme l'équipe de france de rugby au
final c'est bien à une combinaison vous
prendrez sept fous des six échecs ouais
tu veux aller mater ou pas notre sens il
faut prendre la great food a plus de
temps à lire la suite pour prendre la
torah temps sur l onu à tour et assuré
hier soir au mieux la nuque je faisais
fausse hommes voilà bien joué ouais
peut-être ses quatre plus de marche
avant peut-être faire ces trois là ces
trois groupes ans et trois salles à
ferney bahia foot est roi il peut faire
avec ça que je vous ai trois fuites et
l'alluré de castets ouais c'est une
finale tous deux corps opposé moi je
pense qu'elle est beaucoup mieux pour
les blancs celle là laurent parce que tu
en penses
mais avec f 5 fu g7 et ce qui peut
arriver ça devrait pas suffire en
salaire mules et menons mais il ya le
temps au regard des glaces plus qu'une
seconde fait à yad or cela il fait le
spectacle et adore ça et sur m6
maintenant il va à dame il perd le fou
eps est hyper le fou parti il a bien
tourné un c'est incroyable mais ok mais
t'as pas le droit de perdre ça à mes
regarde car il n'a pas encore perdu on
n'a pas encore perdu mais il serait trop
mal autant un entre-deux c'est terminé
c'est fini ok c'est terminé dans ses
lectures de la mauvaise couleur mais il
va pas échanger et oran s'est
complètement terminée ça c'est facile
même en v3 ouais c'est un concours à b3
pour faire croire qu'à 3 des 5 pour même
je te laisse le curage s'il n'est pas
dangereux
ah non et ce rien je ne te cache pas que
je suis déçu voilà pour le monde du
début de match j'ai l'impression qu'il a
un peu craqué sous le soleil n'a pas vu
tout ce qu'ils avaient été probablement
il est il a souhaité
mais tu vois et en plus il a été cédé à
un choix c'est un choix très pratiquant
il a mis à tremper seul choix très
pratique
tu vois c'est beaucoup plus facile à
jouer avec les blancs après exclusion
des 6 impasse et vraiment c'est l'enfer
pour les noirs c'est mal ça fait mal
avec h4 et compagnie enfin pu voir alors
4 5 serait d'accord l'espagnol alors
quatre cavaliers or le fougueux il va
faire le faux et ne non non mais t'as un
peu en retard par rapport à moi
bizarrement d'accord je vois les coûts
très légèrement avant tout en fait tt
était sûr tu as comme pour tout en
feintes et quasi en direct marron ges
comme la wii ware et non mais on est
même endroit mais je vais avoir le
serveur qui va un poil plus vite pour
moi bon c'est pas grave c'est que sur
les tous premiers coups que c'est un
très léger décalage puisqu'après au
racing 4 cavaliers tout ce qu'il ya de
plus classique ou et les voilà les noirs
ont échangé le le fou contre le cavalier
blanc et voilà il joua structure déficit
de structures pour les blancs mais bon
ça se joue donc là on va essayer de on
va essayer d'échanger le foot case
blanche tu vois avec les tactiques sur
des quatre ont fait qu'elle prend des
cadres pas sûr non
la tactique marche il a fait des cas non
il n'y a pas fait qu'elle prend des caps
cas il prend des quatre cavaliers
prendre puis on prend vous prendrez
cette dame traversait tu reprends des 4l
et des blancs médecin mais c'est un truc
thématiques qui marchait pas là et
maintenant ils le monarque et prend des
cafres masquera enfin une variante
l'option de quatre ans prises exactement
donc il faut qu'il fasse quelque chose
soit des feux mais en général tu n'as
pas envie de dormir mais la position
comme ça soit floue des trois quilles et
il a infligé quatre tu mets la pression
sur le plan des 4 way il faut 3 tu peux
pas vraiment pas ce que je vais prendre
des quatre à ce moment là il perd 1,4
après donc en fait ici un problème pour
les objets sur des seuils ne s'est pas
tarie l'a pas obtenu davantage de
facteurs non c'est c'est quoi c'est dans
leur essai dans le sénégal c'est
à peu près moi j'aime bien je prendrais
n'aura en fait moi pas sûr j'exagère un
petit peu en fait n'a pas de souci à se
faire avec des normes annoncé que
radisson sas ou cavaliers et les blindés
blancs près ont pas de moyens d'ouvrir
le jeu tu vois ou alors il faut faire f
4 mais elle reste 4 pour 10 voix pour
réaliser f4 c'est la croix et la
bannière
il faut sortir la dame faut faire un
petit coup de jets 3 pour protéger le 4
et si tu prends le cavalier ans et 5,6
comprends bien il reprend et cavaliers
va aller vers des six exactement et or
là c'est sûr je suis mieux placé sur que
téméraire mais bon j'ai 4 tu vois fuissé
libre et j'écoute finalement avec un peu
de retard
j'ai toujours toujours c'est toujours
avec toi retard c'est fou ça changeait
pas quoi tu vois il faut qu'ils
organisent des attaques à aller le roi
mais bon je suis pas convaincu que
lui-même y croit-il dès lors il croire
ça suffit 1h et pas d'un match 5 3 2
mais bon c'est vrai que t'as rien ouais
sur la gelée de fer kg 6 jeux même
peut-être toit sur lequel tu te fais kg
6 h cinq cavaliers avec la 4è tu viens
te et il faut prendre comprend des
projets trop sa carrière je suis en
train de montrer way et la pareille en
fait en fait c'est ma pointe je veux
faire kg 6 au prochain coup et même si
je pouvais pas récupéré le pion ce
serait pas si grave
bon je préfère équipements mais ça
serait pas dramatique
est ce que je peux à un moment donné
prendre en c5 et jouer sur le fait que
le cavalier très loin de la casse des
six ouais mais là tu me fuis jacques
hazell 4 mais c'est possible tu vois
pour s'assurer que j'arrive pour 24
n'essayez pas facile là parce que quand
même pas très loin de la caserne cadre
du coup le mec
on se rapproche donc il peut virer ils
peuvent y être fou de cases blanches
s'il a envie anjou ainsi tout simplement
mais est-ce qu'on peut pas faire du faux
f1 h quatre fois h36 question qu'il
fasse se fout en fait il est tellement
inutile mais c'est pas évident et noir
ont pas trop de
pas trop de plans il faut déjà y
organiser à 6 tours et pour pouvoir
reprendre de la tour avec six camarades
d'organiser des trucs essaye d'organiser
des défaites de mining et j'ai toujours
plein projet dans la vie mais en fait tu
veux faire la f6 je veux te fais un
genou faire trop de trucs on n'en peut
plus quoi faire
ouais on est dépassé là on se dit le mec
a trop d'idées j'essaie de trouver des
plans mais c'est cool c'est cool je
chambre par chambre
ouais j'ai bien compris au contraire
c'est ça qui est cool doit éponger cas
doigt les dégâts les cavaliers tu vas
faut je pense qu'il faut se lancer dans
le dégage là pour remonter au score
à mon avis il veut faire un tour h 4 ou
tour gerda beau bon il arrive à ramener
leur tour la tour en béret sert à rien
mais notre tour et après tu vois ce que
tu fais non mais tu vois il veut faire f
6 voilà il veut faire et si c'est
évidemment et reprendre d'une pièce
ingles adam évidemment c'est mickaël
trop de temps va l'être ou bien joué
tu prends trop la confiance tu prends
trop la confiance à les tours f6 on
tente un piège ça ne sert à rien
attention ils attaquent double attaque
et les deux pions sur dur à défendre
et attention si je te prends un des deux
pions t'es pas très bien bam et on prend
juste 5 e rev 7 en l'air la fin mais ça
non vous avez si on commence à faire
foot est roi il va y avoir tout réduite
ouais ouais non non elle est lé patek
cette position depuis depuis le départ
d'air mais peut-être on peut faire
damage 5 d'entourage 4 allée à fond dans
l'esprit attaché à la tactique
maintenant à tour g4 ça va se terminer
sa masse se terminer ce système ça
sérieux dans un bain de sang ce truc je
sais pas mais sa fin la tour enfermé tu
vois henri vii
non ouais surtout reprend j'ai cinq
tours pranger 5 d'un projet 5tourcoing f
cette fois je sais pas mais ça ça pue
quoi mais bon
mais si ça marche ça marche tu sais
c'est comme ça les échecs pas grave
c'est devenu très concret un ben si ça
marche ça marche tu fais tu vois au
prochain coup s'il fait h4 avait
finalement
garçons de plus il garde son club plus
bon ça c'est pas terrible parce que la
structure
voilà les patins il fait assister bon ça
veut dire que tu es plus pauvres gars je
peux faire hk rattraperait je fais
d'alger de tatev 3 je sais pas tu vois
je peux commencer à organiser après
j'étais correct à tour en f4 moi je vais
te faire un coup de jets 6 avant la
soirée très très bien placé c'est très
très bientôt
non mais oui tu as raison wayne on voit
le truc c'est que la tour f 4l et
brûlant be there mais moi j'ai envie de
faire tour h4 damage 5 et puis tout à
l'heure mais le truc c'est que ça marche
plus maintenant c'est pour ça que je
voulais faire damage savoure des
champions et en faisant naviguer la tour
eiffe cas de l'autre côté
ouais c'est pas vrai mais probablement
ça marchait pas et là là là je mens 3 et
5 par contre parce qu'un cavalier ou
cinq à la fin donc ils protègent et il
empêche un peu f6 ça je reviens à didon
du coup avec son tournoi et elle fait
une paye son tournoi n'ont ils pas trop
vite et actif il s'est de nouveau une
belle partie puisque tu as une belle tu
as une belle phase de jalousie au fait
qu'on a affaire à deux gros défenseur là
depuis depuis le début du match on sent
que les défenses prennent le pas sur les
attaques
et là je peux pas en voir parce que la
maintenance et magnus qui en dépendent
oui mais il avait fait injurier tout cas
pris le pion et une phase défensive il a
très bien défendu la gare des pions et
maintenant qu'est-ce qui veut faire avec
son roi il veut ramener son bras de
l'autre côté je veux faire quoi
je sais pas ce qu'il va faire peut-être
gagner un peu de temps pour voir et puis
et l'orangé deux siècles que tu fais des
noirs c'est ça le problème se coudoient
fils et décale mystérieux tour à il
atteint il ya tant il joue vite
cette technique norvégienne sentais pas
très bien jouer vite et attend pour des
pour des jours meilleurs
attends attends les jours meilleurs
c'est pas si mal
ça peut marcher est ce que tu as envie
de tenter tour f6 dans sa marche pas et
qu'elle prend des bills regarde toi et
ça qu'ils veulent ils veulent échanger
cette tour finalement way du coup s'il
fait plus on prend elle aura peut-être
du f6 un jour et du f k way dont il veut
pour preuve c'est maintenant une
connerie mais quand en plus ils donnent
trois caps toi ouais mais si tu fais
rien je fais quoi rien en fait
epci f6 pas mal si toute façon il
fallait qu il ne s que je me risque
occupions fion prend j'aurais vraiment
pas jouer ça mais bon c'est concret
après tout reprend du coup pour prendre
plus tôt je vois pas trop ce qu'il fait
après il fait comment ap amman il veut
faire être quatre cinq maintenant et
laurent pas mal joué ouais pas mal pas
mal comment il s'est dit dépatouiller
avec ses tours gg etienne bacrot qui
m'envoie un message sur skype en me
disant elle est sortie les pop corn
mais c'est peut-être lui à nawel du coup
je sais pas qui en a la garde
mais ce que je sais qu'il ya un os dans
le nez ça peut pas être dans ma demande
pardon jeudi j'ai vu qu'il y avait un
appel dans notre chatte aussi et comme
le mec est classé 2750 sur une chaise
comme ce qui est assez fort donc c'est
forcément un fort grand maître si c'est
pas toi que c'est pas fin ça peut être
pas mal de monde mais ça peut pas être
non pas une masse de monde ça peut être
etienne éventuellement être etienne
ouais donc là il a réussi à se faire f 4
f 4 tranches destin qui l'a appris du
pillage donc maintenant il est très très
bien là on dit que c'est jude où ça tu
vois un site avait dit que ça à jouer
bien et en plus il m'a envoyé il ya là
il m'a envoyé des pastilles et on a
filmé toute petite erreur dans la vidéo
et j'ai été réfutée par jules donc mais
il faut faire des arts dans les vidéos
pour laisser les gens à réfuter ouais
voilà encore plus c'était un truc dans
la filiale deux pions être way la finale
de pions en fait elle était si l' effet
au lieu de 1,5 si j'écris français ça
qu'en fait ça gagne et quand même mais
mais différemment
ouais et c'était moins jolie laisse à
gagner quand même ce que j'avais raté et
donc la grille choo qui est quasi
gagnant donc il assad mais il va il va
avoir son petit on veut pas ses attaques
sur le exactement à quand il fait aussi
six menace il me l'a ce matin donc la
magnus et où j'ai ayad mb 21.5 qui se
regarde attention adam b2i offerte aux
rêves de nom qu'est ce qu'il veut faire
sur dame b de l'est chez dams est assez
bien vu lui de faire des messes 2 mais
là là là je pense que ton poulain va
devoir bien sûr mais vous mon poulain
est très bas il est très résistant
donc là je suis obligé plus ou moins te
faire pour prendre quatre haies dames b3
tu vois et aussi te fais dame prend des
trois mais ça peut être terrible non
mais je m l'adamant f5 au pire je ne me
fera pas d'échec enfin quoique tu
pourras faire j'ai six bombes à voir on
va voir ne bougeons pas les pièces à
toute façon va regardons l'armée à faire
surtout paribas je te fais dame d après
ce que j'avais dit en fait joué les
tours en lmp1 et en fait les malins de
fer d'amener un certain fc souhait de
faire d'amasha non parce que surtout
pressé je voulais faire reprendre 6 3 8
tu vois et au moins je protège un peu ça
et peut-être damas chose fait damage la
phaze à la finale de plus été par yapi
yapi
pariant dallage de ripoux et ma sphère
damage de l'otan pour moi ou alors fallu
quelques finales de pions alors jules si
vous écoute calcule la finale deux tours
mais elle est compliquée cette finale
puis en mai le plus rapaces est apparu
n'a joué que moi même si tu as créé
d'options passé lié à priori salaires
perdant même pour et blanc donc larroy 8
et dames france et 7 et j'espère un père
paix avec le nord mais je crois qu'il ya
un père parce que je peux vous pourrez
pas passer par s 4 non mais en fait je
veux revenir avec la dame cette fois à
mes pastur parce que j'ai toujours le
purin bah oui voilà bonne chance pour
calculer un passionné du jeu s'avère
perdre ça peut perdre
bref ça qui adam g iii dame prend on
reprend 1,5 ça peut être tendance non
mais attends enfin peut pas tu peux pas
déçu peut pas nous faire ça il fait c5
c6 ouais ça va pas marcher
bref 4 à 40,3 centimes aux jo tempo ah
non je pense ça va gagner ça va tenir
aux cinq à trois décès 6,3 8,7 3,17 et
non comme effet dès cette recette il va
perdre incroyable c'est fini incroyable
regard d'ange de letat de fidal
voilà c'est fini non mais ok mais je ne
peux plus je ne peux pas supporter ça
mais tu vois que tu échoues une fois
qu'il a eu à prix à 2 tu vois et ils
croient ils auraient pu la jouer avec
damev trois échecs dames f4 en plus avec
un temps de plus elle a gagné quoi
peut-être croire à gagner bassila meyer
qui repasse la seule canal idée mais
c'est s'il avait gagné un set en quarts
le roi a tablé sur des mètres quand je
te connais peut-être dame prend des
trois échecs aussi ouais mais bon du
coup sur les 3,5 le m'échapper avait
peut-être pas de finale je sais pas mais
magnus a l'air très content well as t il
à il prend la confiance ch 4 6 au
cinquième coupe
attention c'est le tarif 1 donc là ça y
est plus de théorie alors ça j'ai jamais
regardé pour lui vous préviens c'est du
freestyle complet ouais quatre heures tu
vois ça change un peu
non mais les gens disent et une branlée
c'est pas vraiment une branlée comme ont
essayé sur la dernière fois c'est très
chaud ça se joue à chaque fois
les parties sont très chaudes
effectivement et là il a mal qu'ils
aillent pas le temps de calculer tu vois
ça joue au feeling et sage
finalement au tempo en fait ce qu'il a
pensé qu'ils pouvaient faire c5 c6 et
secret à deuxième fois passé ce qui
était vrai mais en fait quand manu ses
recettes ses six qui ont entièrement en
3d s'il peut pas pousser les deux donc
c'est ça qu'il a récité très risqué
comme décideur très très risqué pour un
bon maintenant on se demande pourquoi il
a joué 4 tu vois enfin c'est une
catastrophe
alors je te fais des singles 1 tient
fabien a gagné le dans la dernière
partie les pronostics et très heureux il
a trouvé d'alger 3 qui entre en finale
le pion non mais voilà il dit qu'il
arrête parce qu'il est trop au dessus du
game d'accord faites pas dire on va se
lancer dans une nouvelle carrière qui ne
va plus jouer aux échecs en fait il va
simplement jouer au pronostiqueur départ
complet et très fier de lui et bddp se
demandent en fait bourrache quatre
marques dans cette structure s'est
jamais une catastrophe mais bof quand
même tu vois bon là je suis parce qu'il
a fait un coup de messages ou quelque
chose comme ça par moments il ya maxime
bien écrit dans l'est je me fais
chambrer par tout le monde j'en ai marre
quoi tout le monde me chambrent je le
fais chambrer de partout c'est affreux
dessin donc maintenant comment il faut
organiser essais j'ai envie d'organiser
encore la poussée ou 5 pour les blancs
sans perdre pions tu vois si possible et
c'est très compliqué
jean cavalier enfin je vais te jeter
changé et la bière puis on prend 4,2 me
prend des heures les finales doivent
être quand même pas mal pour les noirs
bon pas évident récipient prend des cinq
vrais mecs de pure h4 ça puisse avoir la
coc c'est la cata toute façon laurence
faut que je te dise un truc si magnus
commence à gagner à écraser gris tchouk
tu vas être très très heureux et on va
être obligé de parler de dax en pro d2
c'est si tu continues on va aborder des
sujets les sujets qui fâchent avant que
thierry lacroix a plutôt coin thierry
lacroix oui je connais d'ailleurs attend
deux pénalités de l'histoire tu parles
de la pénalité
dans quel match n'ont en général je vais
l'écrire il étire les pénalités tu vois
il mettait été très très bon
oui oui dont il tirait les pénalités va
changer du passé d'une pénalité ratée
non non non il tirait qui avait pénalité
et il est très adroit et donc toi tu es
un peu aller au stade
ouais moi je serai peut-être qu'on
n'était jamais là j'ai arrêté ouais ça
me plaît je suis moi même temps pro d2
enfin mais tu rigole mais pas juste pas
une petit roxy moment détente mais je
regarde la pro d2 de temps en temps sur
sur eurosport ouais ouais et alors c'est
sympa ouais ça joue pas mal ça joue pas
mal bon temps mais il m'arrive de voir
dax dax qui fait une belle saison
d'ailleurs un d'accord non ils ont ri
joue pas cette année je suis pas du tout
ben il joue mieux que great show de ce
soir est baratin cinq parties sont des
îles et paris librement bien danser la
tension allait vraiment bien dans lequel
30 millions de fois tu vois il va il ya
peut-être qu'ils annulent faut arrêter
l'hémorragie je pense offert nul dans
celle là et on ait gagné une partie
comme dirait mur tu as là me prend b2
tour adhère menace pour preuve cette
attention tactique
si moi je la vois tempo après quoi il ya
des choses qui tombent pas dans le
panneau mais roy fuite est ce que je te
fais pas tout premier set quand même
l'enjeu te fais fou prend ses cadres et
je suis un peu mieux c'est fou ça il ya
encore réussi avec ce lâche 4 servi à
rien n'est encore ici est mieux on
pensait d'eux on arrête de dire que h4
ne sert à rien pourquoi tu pourquoi tu
vois il assure mattei lui ai acheté un
cas où il faille rachat très bons coups
gérante histoire était mené six attaques
c4 et manas tour
ça craint ça craint non mais ok là on
est on est on est marc touret fuite
trois fuites non suite et on tire sagnol
a la rage d'un final de fautes que
reposer aller inapte et aurait fait
attention demeurant ces 400 m dames f5
non ça marche pas tout rose sept tours 8
quand même laisser ce qui m'embêtait
j'avais peur de ça en fait
enfin il va continuer je te fasse ou
deux je reviens avec madame je sais pas
trop comment mais j'avais la meute
amsterdam à 3 mais bon là même cinq fois
c'est ce que je pensais au départ et
c'est comme ça surtout reprend fou prend
2,8 qui te fait roi g7 et tout à l'air
de bon il ya eu dans ces cas là bas j'ai
peut-être fait repousser sa non faussée
5 adam ces trois quart monde nouvelle c3
la 3g ça tu es fou ces cinq mois j'ai
cette fosse 6 quand même kiko
intermédiaire menace que tu dois bouger
adam je me lasse dams est donc obligé
d'aller aux cinq je pense non mais ça
nous a proposé avec les dames sur
l'échiquier roi faible laurent en blitz
contre manu ce qui a quatre minutes
contre une minute trente
effectivement quand tu te présentes
comme ça ça n'a pas l'air
t'as pas envie d'être à la place de
getxo qu'à ce moment là mais moi je te
vends pas du rêve
ouais tu me vends pas du rêve surtout
qu'il était bien enfin tu vois il avait
dû position quand même très confortable
il a fait une combine son kg 400 kg 4 ça
marche et pas des tours mais bon il va
il va y va des troupes voilà il a il a
trouvé un plan je pense qu'il va mettre
un terme à l 6,6 pouvoir sont fous
investis soit son rang g7 mais ça peut
être évident écrite maïs ils font b6 oui
mais en agissant comme plus sains et h5
qu'est-ce que c'était bien joué avec ap
bah ouais enfin moi je sais toujours
avocat 2 h 4 après peut-être 3g cette
maintenant ah oui il ya pions projet 6
intermédiaire qu'est le voir et alors
ben pourquoi pas réduite a réduit quand
même les
non c'est bien je pensais qu'ils
allaient prendre je n'ai pas vu fou et 8
en fait je pensais qu'on allait réussir
à faire puis on prend h5 du cool mais je
ne vois rien des noms ça va ça va c'est
nul c'est sûr cellule objectivement mais
si tu veux mais le problème c'est le
temps ces machins on vient d'apprendre
et même quelques-unes niveau il vaut
mieux qu'ils tiennent tellement ça sera
dur pour le moral
non mais enfin
malheureusement pour le moment laurent
joffrin va j'y crois plus trop quoi
enfin autant déjà un match j'étais choix
n'était pas moi supporter alors ça je
suis un vrai supporters tu vois mais en
plus après après une heure de marche à
plein temps non mais des fois j'ai
l'impression de jouer le maintien tu as
faim je suis avec une équipe
enfin si 16e de ligue 1 enfin tu as evil
quoi j'ai battu santé 3 je me dis bon ça
va je reprends je joue a mis off je me
prend 3-0 tu vois là bas c'est pour
chambre à faire en même temps qui ne va
pas sa détient ses jours située à 16
heures mais c'est avec la terre c'est
que tu penses à l'isard contre
saint-etienne c'est une bonne chose
puis après tu as tellement que juste
s'être grèce et ses standards quoi mais
bon il dalila tient bien pour le moment
les fous ses doigts il a peint d'après
capable yade mb 7 ou vois moi j'essaie
d'échangé et les dédales péniblement pas
même à la finale fou de couleur reposer
mais le truc en plus c'est que les
syndicats aient pas miley rafid ahme des
canadiens ont une petite affaire dalmat
cette dame est sa taille se passe en
justice d'amos et je pense qu'ils
voulaient faire des mauvais 2 le vicieux
de mes blessures de 9,6 y avait eu six
échecs mais bon je suis patient puis en
trois ans si on prend à huy à tanger été
déconnecté la merci ce que t'as pas être
actif en une heure
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et wap et sur
f5 c'est sa part encore pour les prix ou
que tu puisses tu devines un coup
peut-être un moment donné tu joue au
même jeu quoi alors le podium maintenant
je veux qu'à 3 g7 se rassurent il se
passe pas grand chose
oui tout mais c'est vraiment archi nul
en fait tellement tu peux tellement pas
progressé il faut que tu donc tu fasses
g4 g5 amour et même comme ça qu'est ce
qui va se passer faut que tu paies des
réseaux de maths et de toute façon il y
aura toujours des pertes est donc
atteint 9,5 ça marche pas on savait pas
les pions à tu pourrais faire de même
cinq échecs et tout est changé mais là
tu peux pas est-ce que tu as lu de vauré
ce qui d'ailleurs ont parlé de ça tout
ça va être le rang avec laurent avec ça
vient je relis je leur lis souvent le tu
veux dire le tome sur les finales à le
groupe qu'un oui on élu place de boîtes
qui mais celui là je le relis jc de
refaire régulièrement parce que je
n'oublie lâche et oubli ou non le truc
horrible ouvrit le bouquin le plus
torride de l'histoire des échecs à lire
en sept ans le voir donc voilà il lui
fixe d'avaler du fixe je pense qu'il
fixe d'ailleurs mais ce qui peut pas
faire un six à 6 sur helpe adam prend
évidemment cette très mat et enfin peu
importe assise toute façon est bon bah
c'est son nom mais je pense que tu as de
la culture à saint qui veut que le fou
tu vois peut-être là c'est une annonce
je pensais que voulait peut-être place
un chip ou un moment donné avec un fou
qui non protégés ouais mais je pense que
c'est
il peut pas les faire tous ces cas il va
essayer d'organiser tous ces gars là
mais c'est bien joué il ya toujours ce
problème du temps lorrain pour gris
toute malheureusement assez histoire sa
vie un certain m j'ai dit ne vd remise
place fois je vais dire mais j'ai pas il
m'a dit c'est comme si l'écho avaient
plus peur ou là c'est ce que tu me
demandes c'est ce à quoi en gros c'est
de bien gérer mon temps c'est comme si
tu demandais à l'écouté plus avoir peur
et je les dis bah ouais d'accord ok t'as
raison
je te demanderai plus jamais excusez moi
j'adore si j'oubliais replacé après
jurés jure devant d'après non je te
raconter la partie qu'android à sec la
en crète
c'est juste double choc et aux vitesses
est une double charge très tôt
tu vois c'est pas le truc que tu vas
perdre à l'ouverture a priori il au bout
de quinze coups sacha il ya cinq minutes
tu vois en fermant c'était juste le mec
qui fait part à flanquer tôt ils y ont
fait deux phases a reçu tu t'es très bel
en effet ne vois pas qui ne comprend pas
sa double casquette au en fait tu vois
tu ne l'as pas de perdre tout de suite
là allez bon enfin légèreté un fou en
baignoire vous en g2 et enfin pourquoi
le mec là c'est fou de manière aussi
bizarre puis enlevée par lille en v2
c'est une stratégie cachée tu as il se
dit que là comme si c'était la première
fois tu vois ok sur b3 et réfléchie 25
minutes
mais dit il est en train de choisir le
pas le repas du soir d'appeler le resto
évidemment je ne sais pas quoi afficher
une fois je vais demander il m'a dit je
sais pas quand il va tomber la norme et
son horrible orange enrichit les réussi
à lui mettre de roy halladay a mangé
cette île était sais pas comment il a
fait encore il a il a réussi à faire g4
g5 il est bon qu'il va tomber en plus
des trucs hyper g6 taille est terminée
incroyable incroyable il a fait non non
c'est fini les changes des riches est
pacifié la dame angers cet homme c'est
une grand part parce que tu vois pas
arriver en fait non hallucinant et tu
sais pas où je trouve finalement un faux
tcc après l incroyable cette partie
merci ceinture agassi alors est-ce qu'il
va lui c'est hallucinant laurent le
niveau de carl scène quand même parce
que là on a quand même un grand green
shoots quoi il faut souligner en face à
roanne on l'a quand même il a craqué
plusieurs foires ont près de la finale
des pions c'est un truc que tu fais cité
sur plaque trois secondes tu vois non ça
c'est la patiente spécial pardon non non
viser c'est vrai mais bon j'hesite loi
de 2006 lortie marshall avec ak d'accord
qu'un disque et james marshall le prêt
classique avec à quatre voies la houle
et les noirs essaye normalement voilà
fois fuite
si tu peux joueurs des cinq hommes ont
coûté plutôt comprend pas réduite une
cité ris pas tu vas être moins bien en
fait est ce qu'on peut faire genre qui a
aidé deux cavaliers f1 qu'avait lieu le
3 tu vois cavalli avait cinq frères et
des deux mains il ya peut-être faire
qualifier 4 qui va du coup parce que là
il yd'autres rb4 mais à mon avis sur
qualité de ford et le dessin vingt et un
moment il faut le site avait à faire
marcher des cinq dans le manquez pas mal
je ne veux pas je ne veux pas calculer
c'est fou c'est sain il sent le foot
c'est une autre école vous c'est ça que
je ne comprends pas franchement là je
suis des passages sur le foot pour faire
des 6 es tu joué une heure quand gueule
tu vois où tu as perdu autant mais
finalement les blancs pas jouer ma c4
fait des six jeux fait cavalier trois
jambes et donc ayant f5 et je vais te
claquer en abscisse ouais mais non en
fait je recueille 3 par exemple sur
kaleme ça que j'ai de faire cavalier
seul et normalement devrait jouer à 15,6
super 15 6 tu vois mais j'ai pas encore
je prends corps perdu dans une autre
école fou 3 oui je compte me fous des 16
bien marc le seul problème dans cette
position pour les noirs s'ils se font
recette
parce qu'elle est la structure des trois
ou quatre et ils jouent pas tellement
donc temps que t'arrives pas à organiser
j'ai j'allais j'ai vraiment un type de
langage ça ne tarde pas à jouer des cinq
dans de bonnes conditions
ce qui là ne valent quasiment jamais
arrivé parce que le curieux 5 est trop
faible
et bah tu seras tu seras tout juste un
peu moins bien épais avec les noirs
parce que ce front v7 est moins fort que
fois de l'eiblen plus d espace
moi j'aime pas du tout la position faut
marquer l'info marqué un but de laurent
pour sacha encore don't you qui marque
mais on n'a pas marqué encore avec sacha
norge présent
mais on a fait de l'accord ouais ça en
plein match le plus intéressant c'est la
règle à 6 à 6 ans hyper cette partie il
a encore réussi sur l'ouverture y aller
fort alain caillé sur f5 la dame en g3
qu'il a déclaré h 4 qui voit en plus
pour garder parce que le carrière 3 est
quand même très bien placé dans une
structure parce qu'ils contrôlent ils
contrôlent des saints qui contrôlent f5
bon allez fais un petit coup de 1,5 pour
faire peut-être damas car il fait des
six vous arrivez à faire tous ces huit
je suppose mais c'est pas terrible
erreur damas 4g pas c'est assez
tu vois c'est assez simple quoi pour
l'épauler pour les noirs quoi tu es là
tu es en défense
voilà le disent a dit cui seniors non
mais truc c'est que j'aurai bien que le
gritche au toit ils réussissent à lui
placé tu as un knock-out fois ci
réussisse enfin tu as fou j'aime bien la
vacation fo 17,6 vous faire d'avoir deux
je pense
il veut pas faire fou prend à 6.6
pensionnaires prêts déjà y aura une
découverte peut-être québec a way qui a
eu des cas je reviens d'amener un vrai
mais je te prends le foie sites situés
dans les blés qualité as tu utilisais
faut baisser le pib quatrième fois sur
bardon excuse moi alors je raconte
n'importe quoi
ouais et du pays et damas deux jours et
damas deux mais damas de jeu protéger
cette genre un coup de touré fuite vous
prend à six tours à huit ce calcul est
ce que j'arrivais récupéré à cinq je
suis pas mal et des foulées du retard
non non j'ai formule cavaliers ou cette
dame 1 4 nantes et bonté bon c'est moi
qui montrait un peu les variantes ont
été enlevés avec trois balles de set
oui c'est typique tu vois où qu'ailleurs
g6 mais là dans ces structures camp de
kaleah 3 il va les marchés 3 pour les
bleus en précisant même pas jouer h3 et
cavalières g6 et pas et pas toujours
autant de morceaux
qu'est ce que je peux te faire du petit
tour à b1 avec l'idée
2 de prendre la colonne b tout bêtement
ouais c'est pas mal tu vois je lance tu
fais tout reprend tout reprendre réussir
à placer une tour des huit dans
l'exploit d'amadou d'abord je pense que
c'est son idée voilà et toi 8
il n'est ce pas et il est là alors que
les jets si c'est pour chaque poussée kg
6 même s'il me fait g3 je vais te faire
cavalier 7 kg 5
ouais mais ces gens les dps et c'est pas
parce que tu fais avec des blancs
finalement d'affaires cavaillac 4 ici
kerry h 4 et je te dis bah à toi tu
jouais pas ouais et je te fais g5 vous
jeudi n'ont fait qu'un lièvre 5 je vais
prendre et j'ai joué ces six et je vais
commencer à être pas mal mais tu peux
reprendre le mans revenir avec trois
mais on voir quelle justice bon j'ai
joué cinq
bon je sais pas si c'est ok mais
peut-être que je dois faire des quatre
alors ici et quand il ya quatre ans
passionné jeu je vois mes
peut-être pas immédiatement mais gardant
l'esprit tête qu'il faut réussir oui oui
mais quand elle km3 tu vois pour jouer
des quatre c'est pas évident d'ailleurs
il prend son temps pour une bonne raison
l'un parce qu'il faut trouver un plan il
faut décider si tu as envie de casques
autant richard houis a priori faut jouer
des quatre-vents voix sinon tu vas rien
à voir mais en fait y'a pas d'autre plan
là finalement on leur tape sur l'épaule
et thomas il a fait cas les h4
il écoute le stream il écoute de street
peut-être alors soit je te fais cécile
direct mais à ce moment là je tourne un
is a way et si je te fais des 5
ouais tu t'en fous en fait fugué 3 n'a
fait on les écoute il écoute c'est
pouvoir la trouver tous les goûts tomber
si des cinq là tu fais quoi
c'est l'heure je crois mais c'est
pénible en fait tombé six des 5
il me semble bon si je t'avais dit ed
hardy coogi les mieux payés voyez mieux
des saints et saintes dégage
on comprend que je prends ma fille et le
santal carré h4 non mais t'as fait j'ai
trois fins il importe quoi mais il a
très mal géré la carrière 3ème csn tu
vois ça joue tout seul et j'ai réussi
s'est moqué il va essayer de à cavaillon
5e et qu'elle sache je te fais dam des
six parmi les trois professionnels il
est trop impressionnant magnus c'est
vrai qu'il a il arriva il est très fort
dans ses positions espagnol as y est
très fort un peu partout mais c'est une
position espagnole c'est vrai qu'il est
mais moi je comprends pas toujours j'ai
l'impression c'est toujours moins bien
et je remplis coups plus tard il ait
lieu
je sais pas trop
3 comprend pourquoi pas fait d'erreur
c'est juste c'est vraiment c'est attend
peut-être qu'il y ait plus et mieux que
ça voilà il est un peu à taille à quel
point ça kf3 carême et aimer rangée de
1,3 g devrait peut-être après je te
claquant aussi ça être une erreur de
calcul donc à lire 3g 2 n'y a pas
quelque chose avec du fourrage trois
genres kg 5e fois je crois assez beau
quoi moi j'ai deux fois 5 mai 1re price
3 pour un 4 3 3 4 et qui on est alors
attendez en place et au 134 il ne fait
pas évidemment parce que moi c'est
choquant pour les blancs tu vois ton roi
il est quand même pas la dame elle est
aux fraises jarre je te fais un coup de
tourbe et huit ménages est retombé de
trsb 6 tomber vite qui avait si j'ai pas
des tours prend v6 à prendre et 6 damas
huit échecs la fumée ou temps un as tu
vois très très chaud et on réagit à
tamar est la coordination des pièces
c'est juste ça va pas quoi c'est violent
c'est sur les noirs sont pas assez
jamais sur les noirs sont pas moins bien
je fais tomber sa jolie tomber ça va
être sympa parce qu'il a vu quelque
chose c'est très probable est ce que je
fais c'est avec les blancs de faire ces
quatre mêmes sa part un peu anti
positionnelle pour essayer de vie c'est
mon cavalier sur des 5 tu vois pour pour
essayer de bloquer telle arrivée de tes
pièces sur blanc quoi ouais
peut-être mais c'est ce cas peut-être x
2,5 non j'ai pas encore à toi t'es cap
c'est pas mal ça c'est pas très
esthétique mais c'est vraiment pour
tourner un tour c'est ça
à côté surtout v8 qui avait tourné un
tour t4 qu'est ce que c'est ah les dames
à huit est peut-être prendre à sainte
non passage à huy prendre ça un petit
pion au passage oui ça va lui personne
n'est très très heureux de ce genre mais
voilà il pointe mais bon dam des deux
fous ces deux dames des trois peut-être
qu'il entend fin green shoots leila il
s'est quand même pas mal réorganiser
rien de ma vie vraiment je te fais un
petit coup de pub à 8 pour voir comment
tu non mais je fais ces quatre sur damas
huit je protège le cavaliere avait pas
mal profond car oui là c'est vraiment
pas mal ces quatre exacte tout un
lastours gère attention à joli tour g1
avec avec cavaliers trois échecs faut
que je tenais à tuer juste dam des trois
c'est un chip hausse à ce ma part très
fort en finalement ouais mais quand même
ça commence à jeux commencent à rôder
autour autour autour de torrent ou trois
points ça peut être ça peut mal se
terminer
bah j'ai passé deux pièces problème on
donne trop envie de faire tout rue89
j'aime pas avoir vraiment dame eu trois
fils qu'il a prévu sur tours 8
mona squash 3000 touristes paraît très
très fort dame e3 c'est très étrange
comme coup à première vue mais après
vous faut souligner que les joueurs
voient beaucoup plus de choses que nous
un bon et on n'en sommes pas que des
choucas plus de temps vu que c'est comme
ça depuis là depuis des parents fait
impression que les troubles il
commençait partie avec avec 2002 - ce
sont en fait non oui fait pas tout à
fait sûr malheureusement il n'y a pas de
tactique mais non mais tu as outreau
fois je reçois cheikh adam 17 peut-être
encore plus fort menace matt cavaliers
six échecs il se passe quoi surprendre
mais ça il a juste raté parce turiaf et
c6 et pour des femmes cueillent à foot
et 5 justice est très bizarre
non mais il a raté ça arrive mais je
comprends pas froid gris tout réfléchi
autant feinte à cinq secondes ou non
mais va-t-on des caisses coeur waouh
non mais j'en peux plus comme quoi tu
sais pas jusqu'où des tapas sur ces
dessins qu'avait pour éviter tour
restera de tanger 1 c'est ça qui l'avait
vue d'accords essai brillant fantastique
et je bourre 8 pour eux et je me lève
ton jerman mais tu peux pas trop j'avais
quand même
ouais mais je te fais tour g1 ou f1
amène à tourner sur f4 j'ai l'impression
durant les joutes à tour à 2 à nantua du
half outils contrôler mon cancer cette
fois un coup de pouce et si c'est un
coup déviation nord mais il avait bu
évidemment il se retrouver comme non
plus comme par magie
non mais j'en peux plus j'en peux plus
vous êtes plus objectivement pas sûr et
le plus âgé de 5 à sa droite nul mais
bon non mais j'en ai marre j'en ai marre
et y est on a non
gageons avec un centième de seconde
attention non il faut qu'il arrête sa
fin est venue quand j'en peux plus
remboursés alors comment ça se passe
cette finale à y perdre y perd un
deuxième qui ont peint ces traîtres il y
aura trois fous des sols non mais ce pas
aya défend bien on n'a pas perdu au
deuxième avant elle dit ça hyper
deuxième non non il perd pas hyper pas
une perf à monsieur âgé 4 il le tient il
le tient il le tire pour le monde
laurent fau aussi
quand même non ok il a plus de temps là
il est un peu remonté autant tour en me
trompant de la tension s'est terminée
lorsque ces quatre aussi il y as roi des
cats
waouh ça défend bien les sens très très
bien et me va pas du tout il ajouté
il faut b737 on prend aux deux tours
prend 17 projets d'autres gagnent à feu
a éclaté je gagne a fait le tour ou pas
pas si sûr manua gagnant tu va claquer
la tour sur un pion et puis comme ça est
agréé depuis on passerait comme ça
un petit coup de moins bien si je pense
oui pour calculer un peu quand même ou à
4 c 7 à 3 pts ah oui non et pékin
il a fait tomber quatre maintenant
j'ai à tomber 5 web si elle est réussie
sur ses cinq as well as ton prend on
reprend et g2 ouais mais allait mal
placé à et tu vas faire j'ai un âne sur
l'échec
ouais et j'étais au courant c'est fini
et c'est terminé
ça me fait un non mais t'as pas d'en
perdre un c'est sûr y'a peut-être avoir
des idées de pat je sais pas tu pas
j'aurais essayé de te pathé moi j'essaie
de pas d'échec cette dame c'est cette
dame c'est un c'est pas tout à fait fini
encore loin non mais je crois pas il n'y
a aucune case où tu fais pas tu ouais
mais j'ai pas être obligé de prendre je
pense qu'il va lui il lui donnerait lui
donne toi bond pas les plaindre quand
c'est pas son truc
la raison n'est jamais donnée d'options
méthode à madame il être obligés quand
même deux filets sur un an
ouais j'aime pas trop ce qu'il a
vraiment dit eric de la ligue avec deux
secondes parcours faire mal les
positions de nu qui propose nul si c'est
gris tout je trouve que c'est un peu
ridicule comme ce com com 3 nuls ce que
tu perds du temps et peut-être qu'il
essayait de réclamer la nuit non non
mais les trois fois au tout va tellement
qu'elle va tomber autant à un manuscrit
scène a refusé la vienne ok mais il est
tombé
greek river d'amsterdam hausse est oui
oui c'était bizarre de proposer quel
massacre
c'est la dernière partie dont celle en
dom ouais c'est un massacre laurent
effectivement ça se passe pas très bien
pour paris mais c'est très intéressant
en cas de nouvelles partir le score est
quand même sévère
le score est sévère mais en fait il perd
tous les deux les greens flip
non il perd tout est parti me reste tu
vois moins 10 minutes chacun oui mais
toujours clé et donc c'est assez mauvais
signe pour le bullet quand même faut pas
fait pas vendre la peau de l'ours
tu vois c'est quand même c'est mauvais
signe quand tu les réflexes sont
meilleurs chez en tout cas aujourd'hui
les réflexes sont bien meilleur schéma
news donc ça c'est mauvais signe pour le
bullet ont déjà il ya du retard et en
plus de mal se terminer
on va voir voyons le cas elle est
marrante cette position ou f3 non mais
c'est c'est que c'est quand même très
très très très impressionnant laurent
whale arrive oui puis les finales où il
a peu vu les gammes tout
non mais ça me fait penser à nadal à
roland garros en fait ouais voilà ça les
postes des problèmes en format d'art
c'est ça et où doivent revoir leur trac
même si défend très bien mais on l'a dit
plusieurs fois d'ailleurs d'être chaud
qui se
il a fait quelques très belles défenses
mais là c'est vrai que c'est le score
est quand même la manière quand on voit
même pas en fait comment ils améliorent
c'est incroyable ce qu'il a fait aussi
dans la dernière partie où il rappe
depuis angers 2 ira pas une une
opportunité tactique en fait il est très
très en forme très affûté tu vois les
jeunes qui est très en forme contre sow
est très en forme contre digne des
ambitions qui est juste très en forme en
ce moment en fait il est redevable aux
enfants ouais il aime bien les rapides
et les beats et m
ils en gagnent beaucoup tu vois grande
chaise tour à paris c'est à paris à
paris c'était très chaud avec maximin
ils ont eu la bourrin ouais magnus avait
pas mal d'avancé le dernier jour et en
gros maxime à une journée de folie et
magnus eu un petit coup de moins bien
je crois qu'ils avaient tous trois
points de moins il est revenu sur lui
dont jouer un match de partage en fait
tu vois c'est chaud mais en général
c'est vrai que c'est toi de rapides et
de blitz guéguen quand même en belgique
qui voit il a gagné quand même assez sa
tête avec une grosse mare
non mais c'est ça mon saut mais je crois
qu'il est encore plus chaud en fait un
rapide et vite
la preuve quand il fait il a quasiment
trois mille ans vite et c'est pas un
hasard freud on c'est très bizarre
seconde position
ça va rien dire 960 c'est très étrange
mais c'est autant plus intéressante est
un petit coup de qui coûte quoi les
bizarres ta dernière fuite mais je
voulais faire un petit coup de hache 5
en fait mais par r je prends très dense
et trop défendu en fait ouais et puis
tout la colonne j'ai tu vois le
vis-à-vis va pas être terrible
je crois que c'est très mal avec les
noirs peut-être que je fasse grand roque
ouais mais j'ai de faire du p4 dessin tu
vois c'est horrible je crois que c'est
très très mal en fait tu fais du rock
mais en fait elle j'ai fermé quatre
baies san jose qui avait duré sept
matches à mon avis les noix il faut
qu'ils essayent les shows des genres et
des pièces j'ai montré que leur c'est
marrant sur petit rock des quatre
cavaliers bouche bée 5 pardon des cinq
cavaliers bush qui avait lieu cette
maths ça pourrait être esthétique
d'ailleurs way belle façon doivent en
poser est ce que l'on en croit la
remonte tada à écoute noms nagy croyez
pas non plus pour psg barça tu vois oui
donc bon en même temps tu croyais que
c'était pas le sporting gijon 3 le psg
ouais byron ces grandes quand même allez
peut-être enfin il fut créé en fait si
c'est pas grand chose d'autre à faire au
final 1 mais au matin mais je comprends
pas a fait sur b4 tu vois j'ai de gagner
une pièce en jambes et quatre des cinq
cavaliers cet échec et je te bouffe le x
8 ou je te bouffe la tour je comprends
pas en fait ce qui se passe non il va
peut-être claqué en d4 iphone 4 est
obligé de toute façon il claque ça soit
étayée tu es mal hein c'est pas mal ça
ici un pion mais au moins ils y sont 100
m 2 h 8
c'est une bonne solution pratique qui
voit un bon il est mal et puis en plus
cavalier prend qu à l epr en disant
comprendre faut prendre un tour prend 1
je te fais un coup de tours j'ai eu 8
ouais t'es qui toi d'un coup tu as ton
roi eu deux battus le pré carré alors
j'ai pas d'abord j'ai pas où pranger
cette blague il est la même et ok je
fais toujours 8 lasteyrie d'ailleurs
hattrick pour wes est pas clair c'est sa
sortie quelque chose c'est pas mal ça
avait l'air horrible je pense que
surtout 8 il veut faire des bêtises
ouais mais attention dame f6 way key des
quatre rois rouaroua dans les courants
d'air à droite bien étonnant je pensais
qu'il allait je pensais aussi il va
récupérer laisser récupérer ses cinq
balles a récupéré 1 toute façon pardon
il va le récupérer ces cinq dans tous
les cas non ouais il ya des chances sur
calais ou 4g cavaliers des cats avaient
sur quel prince at il doit y avoir 6 qui
en ferme
j'imaginerais pas sûr j'ai seul mais ce
qu'elle achète à ne pouvait aussi faire
du kava lieu saint calais te jouer pour
du fouet trois échecs et tu vois je te
faire kg 5e je pense oui mais là je sors
par la grande porte quoi je je je
t'attaque la tour je protège 3 ouais ça
c'est pas c'est pas cool ça m'est donc
du coup m6 soit j'aime bien ton coeff 6
et 6 g5 du coup c'est ce qu'il est en
train de regarder ma vie où j'ai fait en
direct c'est pas mal j'espère que ça
fixe ou g5 curage 6 faut que laurent
lafon vraiment une victoire de great
choc là dessus et coauteur c'est pas mal
plus c'est paris romain briffé c'est
vrai que ça va être difficile mais bon
il faut remonter la pente peut-être
comprend ces cinq là tout bêtement il ya
quoi il ya une peau de banane ce que tu
veut peut-être faire cavalier des quatre
maintenant est fou prend le car s'était
pas à cayuga c'est bizarre tu vois cette
bah les cavaliers break très mal placé
mais bon il ya peut-être une idée cacher
je sais pas j'ai pas trop compris sont à
mon avis il veut faire jouer seul il
cherche ses mots et de fer h41 pour mais
bon ce sera moins fort 4 et en fait il
veut il veut garder ce cavalier laxiste
voix pour toujours et on peut le
comprendre c'est quand même c'est quand
même bien joué c'est quand même courage
l'énergie parce que c'était pas évident
bien joué ça c'est pas sûr mais pas
complètement sûr quand même toi tu t'es
quand même tu as tu appris des voix je
peux jouer des saints qui ça peut mal
tourner tout raciste ou pas natoora 6
par a vu laurent joly le petit goût tour
qui soit il est très bien placé soyez
très bien placé c'est à dire truc c'est
quoi ta cavale et seront attachés l'un à
l'autre mais bon ouais ouais ça s'est
passé ou les prendre
ok donc ils arguent et vous faire
cailler france et saint caprais amateurs
mais fou provocatrice pasqua et français
avouent prendre les trois qu'il
prendrait trois d'accord wahou
il faillit en fait qu'ils jouent des
tactiques qu'on n'envisage même pas mais
peut-être tout pour prendre le cas c'est
pas mal oui mais quel français sent
qu'il a toujours enfermés c'est génial
c'est horrible ouais c'est le temps des
jolies ces jolis tours prend 1,4 en
france et 5 c'est très rare d'en faire
une tour en 1 4 magnifique ce qui est
affreux écart à la scène c'est qu'ils te
place des thèmes tactique y voit des
thèmes tactique qui sont pas des thèmes
tactique habituelle non mais c'est
vraiment c'est très bien mais bon c'est
ça va pour gris tout cas m faye pro du
sirha ça va ça va deux bonjour j'ai une
belle colonnes pour 20 tours en béton
tout il est pas terrible j'ai peut-être
j'ai pas c'est pas terrible je pense que
ces gros avantage dans les préaux quatre
jetons temps fougue amie jane campion
prends ça je comprends bien pour eux
quatre ils vont peut-être faire payer si
ce qui est des quatre mais bon
mais je fais un couteau vers d'abord
acheter il joue et tout l'échiquier mené
ça c'est beau non mais c'est pas tu vois
c'est du grand art à chaque fois tu vois
h4 et prend 17 sait jamais non mais
c'est magnifique
enfin y'a rien n'y a rien à dire à
laurent sait pas c'est beau de voir ça
tu vois il a il a créé il a il a créé la
faiblesse sera d'avoir avant que sur le
4 mai la banque ayant des quatre il fera
beau mais je vais te dira je vais te je
vais le prendre à chaque fois non mais
c'est donc là c'est ça al'air terminé
c'est du tout high-level elle est très
très fort de faire jouer 8 1 il vraiment
je n'ai pas tour j'ai fait 6 5 échecs
aussi il va autant que tu vois j'ai
assisté en croit ces six tours g7 bon
soit tous les deux faire et j'ai six
paiement de façon c'est ça qu'ils le
gardent ils le gardent dans la manche
quoi oui bien sûr et on va aller il faut
peut-être que ce n'est pas son problème
c'est sa voix avec les noirs les noirs
peuvent faire c'est serré perd 2,3 et on
dira et oui pas mal ça crée un peu de
jeu un sacha bien joué allez faut
essayer d'aller gratter h4 et puis se
battre quoi ou f4 enfin n'importe quoi
mais un ace et c'est pas mal ça part de
là laurent sa part de l'un sa part du
nul ici et tu reprends tu remarques
après il ya le match du real qui démarre
dans trois minutes
ouais c'est vrai ouais c'est contre qui
c'est un ligue des champions en plus
ouais mais ils sont déjà qualifiés les
mains se passe contre l'hapoël c'est un
club chypriote un même si regard diarra
que les deux premiers quarts d'heure
environ 3 0 ouais on espère avec ce
qu'on peut laurent non mais il y avait
un atletico la dernière fois c'était
beaucoup mieux
c'était beaucoup plus chaud qu'il allait
regarder mais en fait il a mal joué
après le début du match est peut-être
cavalli g6 échec là et oui et j'ai su ce
qu'ils réussissent
et papa qu'elle sait si ce fait il se
fait taper ça il va se faire j'aurais
préféré faire qualifier système que de
laisser ça à 21 heures là tu vas pas te
bats pas tu vas pas te plaindre il est
quasi gagnant leur endroit prend aussi
ses les pions vont débouler quoi et à
beaucoup de concurrents
c'est dans l'esprit laurent c'est un
toit pour nous là sur la chaîne blitz
stream c'est complètement guéant pour
les blancs ça d'accord
le mec a une caisse de moi et là trois
pions en facture est il complètement
conceptuellement il est au-dessu quoi
ouais et tous rêvent de tours et ouais
bah on s'en fout complètement enfin je
sais les red bull avec ça il peut faire
obstacle
ouais mais ça a pas l'air ouais mais il
va faire f 6 3 o6 f7 et tu vas voir
qu'il va gagner un temps presque le pion
à il n'aura pas le temps de passer qui
l'épaulera comme d'hab
oui mais c'est ce qui va se passer cette
prise prise frise vas y vas à le faire
après puis mais peut-être food et cet
échec sur f cet effet salut matsa malik
à l'appel en question a bafoué ça allait
m'attendre
oui oui où
oui en fait je l'achète je voulais faire
plus d'essais 3,5 3,7
il ya bien suite en fait il voulait pas
fini
ou l'orangé prendra juste un petit break
de transport vas-y lors je reviens
taille et j'y crois
boum la pls cosmique que vous vous êtes
pris dans le tchat
vous savez on vous a mis en pl ace
cosmique c'est que le début c'est que le
début les tontons tout peut t'arriver
fou prend f7 bon juste avant la mi-temps
quoi allez les mecs on y croit et c'est
la pls les mecs c'est c'est la pl us ou
17 matches c'est la pls
alors attendez du coup si vous
connaissez vous qui fait de match
n'hésitez pas à faire un petit partage
sur les réseaux sociaux
je remette le lien que j'avais partagé
vous faut partager de partout
suivez le match great chioukh charles
scène en direct et je vais faire je vais
faire un petit bien que j'ai raison et
pour les médias sociaux
dis moi tu y croies tard au mental du
coup bah si tu veux enfin je veux dire
c'est le signe du destin ce matin en 1
pour moi c'est incroyable
après avoir tâtonné quoi en fait c'est
ça c'est intéressant un qui faisait sur
à 5/6 vii à la place alors soudé c'est
fou c'est dingue et roy hill recettes
non pas roux c'est parce qu'elle fit
dame et je te pique le fou mais en fait
tu peux juste poussé à viendrait est en
fait fait tourner 8,3 à 2,7
ouais et si je te fais des 6 dreads ans
ouais non je voulais faire trois des
quatre ou cinq incidents mais ça va être
trop a donc très belle défense de hid a
raté complètement sur cette défense
d'accord alors il ya un break de combien
on fait ça va être très courts à chaque
fois une famille on se fait avoir on a
l'impression que ça repas fin on a ça
donnait l'impression que ça repart tout
de suite tu vas pas te rendre compte de
ça va repartir
d'accord ok donc le score c'est 6 hausse
de 6,9 et finalement c'est pas si mal
quoi pour pour gi joe ben je sais pas je
trouve que c'est quand même cruelle par
rapport au match parce qu'on a perdu
tous les maux macho mais on va dire que
psychologiquement elle fait du bien
celle là
ouais c'est vrai on va voir mais bon
c'est vrai que je pense pas qu'il va
tester à ce score là tu vois c'est un
score serré ça aurait pu le faire per
minute moi c'est plutôt marrant toi tu
vois toute façon il va y rencontre qui
était foutu de tout confort mais c'est
vrai que dix coups avant était quand
même a été archi
il était juste archimédien ce qu'il a
fait il a monté son roi oui il avait
nulle quand il voulait oui quand il est
chaud café poussé 6.8 c'était pas mal
pour protéger le pur ça peut poser
beaucoup de problèmes dans le chat
aurait dit qu'on veut voir nos visages
attend s contenter au pire de toute
façon au vent au vidage d'accord alors
attends je te laisse te remettre la
caméra vite fait on va voir s'ils
agissent rim tiens je vais tout de suite
te dire de toute façon pour le conserver
non on me répond ah tu mangeras pas trop
le csaf ya des faits pas des gestes
qu'il ya du monde dans le chat on veut
prendre une petite respiration mènent
leurs remarques ne remet pas la caméra
tout de suite et sont un peu démarré le
3 + 2 on va attendre qu'ils soient à 21h
21h15 sailor allemand où ça se passe
bien et puis on prendra une petite
respiration pendant le 3 + 2 parce que
tu as a déjà redémarré donc ouais c'est
vrai puis bon on est quand même là pour
voir les joueurs en priorité j'ai enfin
c'est ce que je considère perso
après on pourra se remettre un peu mais
quand je regarde c'est quand même sympa
de voir car le ciel gris chukka puis
vont enfin c'est s'aider grosse star
quoi donc là je vous dis souvent après
cinq des cats voyez pas entrer la finale
et il a fait fausse est bon chez une
petite variante qu'il a déjà joué en
blitz est en rapide et gratuit tu vois
il fait il a réagi tout de suite donc
ils s'étaient préparés
bon allez faut que le gritche là il
gagne ça là il revient à 6 3 tu vois là
on est dans quoi
mais ouais j'y crois pas tellement
tanner je l'espère pas surtout c'est un
peu le problème est là il est il et il
est pas mal game ou c5
ok mais attends j'ai tout de suite calmé
comment il s'appelle john key peau dont
le dans le chat qui est très content
d'être là bas sur le truc en anglais des
caméras des joueurs les matches et tout
ça le truc c'est que ils ont
ils ont la technique en direct en fait
tu vois et nous on récupère toutes les
images sur les sur les strings
différence sur les trucs donc ça demande
une connexion internet et le truc c'est
que ça fait bugger donc enfin si si t'es
pas content tu écoute pas et puis c'est
tout quoi enfin tu vois le truc en uefa
juste nous ne nous laissons pas à
marcher sur les pieds non géré par la
faim l'intérêt quand même premiers du
stream c'est de regarder les parties de
voir les joueurs majeurs par là enfin on
pourrait aussi mais il assure ne voir
nos essais secondaire c'est quand même
très secondaire donc si d'accord tkm là
pour regarder car cette façon masquée
ouais non je suis d'accord ouais donc là
il fait des sacrés bons c'est pas
terrible il faut résoudre ce problème du
cavalier tu vois si tu arrives à la mène
deux points f5 et le cavaliere a aussi
été très bien et baignoire la route est
longue
ça me fait un peu penser enfin ok ça
ressemble pas du tout la position mais
c'est moi qui joue pas mal joué
l'écossaise dont l'aimiez this quand al
kamali pays 6e fois 6 très mal placé tu
vois ouais en fait que tu joues dans
l'esprit sur ces deux pièces là qui
reste bloqué mais la thur moi je suis
riche et 4 franchement tu as peut-être
frange les graves problèmes du pion ces
deux et puis après j'ai cadré f4 quoi
donc d'affaires d'amd cep suppose non
mais c'est pas toi tu tour aussi trop 6
pour empêcher g4 pour toujours genre je
réponde ainsi quand les mecs tu empêches
ces quatre là me prend 6,6 à une
tactique cavalli a faim on va voir je
comprends bien mdr ah il veut il veut
régler le problème du cavalier au smi
prix d'un pion
parce que du coup sûr d'un prend 17 fou
prend 17 tu seras obligé de faire b3 et
encaissent le cas mal à quatre ans mais
il fallait voir aussi que kyle et cet
été en prise et maintenant il sait il va
se venger sur sur ces deux là est ce qui
va vraiment se venger sur ces deux
battus fait comment tu les vois âmes
france essaie d'apprendre d'un procès je
peux apporter
vraiment je suis hyper actif cavagnoud
qui ont des je voulais faire b3 en fait
pour commencer ouais c'est pas mal mais
trois parce que j'ai pas trop de cases
intelligent programme des matins blêmes
et sur damas un je vais te fait refouler
deuxième venger sur des 4
ouais c'est pas mal et en plus tu as
même pas ton prono 5 à huy sur france 2
et t'as pas tout qu'on s'installe à
tours à huit en l'air il va faire c'est
ça que je pense
ouais c'est la partie adam des cinq jeux
clou le pion ces derniers ouais c'est du
très haut niveau ça joue très bien voir
la petite combine êtes vous prend ces
deux fonds prend des cas d'abord
mesdames c'est capcom plus aller sacha
allez petit ça part de là ouais tu
commence à y croire la laurent allard
montana je crois qu'en fait sascha il va
se faire raser en boulet
en fait c'est la dure réalité du truc
que tout le monde que tout le monde sait
mais que perdre ce que tout le monde
fait semblant d'oublier oui c'est vrai
qu'il a l'air vraiment raté complet on
voulait je crois qu'il est en fait ils
voient la pression n'en est pas un
atteint du ciel je me rappelle des
matches la plupart des matchs les
favoris en bullet écrase mais je me
rappelle d'un match à l'époque où il
appelait ça les deathmatch et même
passer même pas le speech est semée y
avait un mec qui était gravement favori
une bulle est et je sais pas ce qui lui
arrive et il a fallu aller le mauvais
roche et il fait défoncer c'est
rarissime un mais tu sais que une deux
en une demi-heure il suffit que tu es un
coup de un coup de mou et ouais ouais
c'est vrai on est d'accord qu'il ya une
chance sur 10 ou une chance sur 20 ou je
sais pas mais c'est parce qu'elle peut
investir même j'ai vu des prédictions où
il disait que ma carte a été favori à
96%
ça me semblait quand même beau énorme tu
vois là mais c'est l'algorithme tue
c'est l'algorithme il ne ment pas quoi
ouais ouais je sais pas j'ai pas en fait
1 96% je pourrais jouer plus tendance à
parier sur des tubes ouais bah quote oui
pour la côte pour la côte mais donc il
fait un petit coup de hache 3 c'est pas
évident de se dépatouiller avec les
bleus en fait de deux tu vois pas ce
qu'il y'a 2 qui prennent finalement
c'est une affaire qui est il et il veut
changer d'air il veut faire mieux tout
de suite je peux échanger faire tour
dernier les pions des cats mais il veut
dire que là que la phase finale a vu ce
qu'on est en train de voir sur
l'échiquier
ouais la finale il veut dire capitale
est archi nul avec les fous de coraux
poser et je pense qu'il a raison
là on voit gris chucky les focus 1 sur
l'écran gritche ou que je ne connais pas
mal parce que je le connais un peu aussi
perso et il a encore il a encore le
visage pas fatigué quoi ils croient non
mais il a encore puisqu'il peut ni la
fatigue le marquand fait gris tchouk est
là pour le moment il n'a encore le
visage enfin tu vois il il est je pense
qu'il s'en qui joue bien quand même tu
vois si il est pas mené 6-2 écrasé tu
vois ce que je veux dire ouais et donc
je sens encore dans son attitude tu vois
le brusque of conquérant tu vois et là
il va les faire à tour à mettre à la
poubelle mais là se trouvait alors à 4
est liquide tout même je te liquide je
fais mieux que de liquider en fait je te
grâce aux pions non pas vraiment mais
c'est sur scène qu'il n'avait pas dû un
fou bien à trois je prends une fois de
vous jeter le choix de direct après ce
prise tombé 5 ou prends mes trois et on
a de cette finale 4 contre 3 mais il est
toutefois opposés même pas en rêve pour
être sûr de gagner faut quand même la
jouer laurent a bien sûr bien sûr
monsieur monsieur normalement il n'y a
pas de risque il va pas être voyais à
pas de géant sur les deux ailes donc ça
va quoi mais ça se tente
certains mais c'est très facile à des
forces finalement poindre parce que t'as
pas tu as peut-être ton seul plan tu
vois cette poussée à 5 mai alors avant
deux sens et à paris l'ex à aller fait
un petit coup de main peut-être tentés
f5 qui on prend et puis on prend h5
ouais mais je suis de faire rage ces 3 6
je suis toujours pas inquiet en fait
ouais c'est exactement ce qui se passe
en effet on trouve tous les coups la
plateforme ça y est on est chaud saillon
vous l'an prochain laurent c'est fini
voilà tu ne nous résisterons pas pour
hachage bien joué et nulle bientôt tout
mon échec d'abord voilà à attend et vous
pourrez vivre à lille a proposé m ouais
ça y est nul il se propose nu la
mutuelle des militants qu'ils ont coupé
le son ça m'arrive
tu veux tu vas rentrer quand tu joues
comme ça c'est mieux de garder le volume
quand même parce que tu entendre les
coûts supérieure une meilleure réaction
non je sais pas c'est parce que je fais
ce métier je suis pas je sais pas ouais
non j'aime bien coupée de vos yeux doux
alors qu'est ce qu'il va faire un retour
alors est ce que quelqu'un a briefé sur
cette ligne et c'est vrai ouais donc la
construire la partie de la première
partie finalement way avec le fameux du
4 mai vlad flad a dû dire quelque chose
quoi c'est fini kouassi vlad rentrer
dans le jeu tu n'a plus aucune chance
là il est obligé quasiment créé infosys
web et 3 to b 2 voilà c'est ça le plan
ouais ça pue quand j'en ai marre alors
mais tu vois c'est un drame est un pur
isoler le maïs appareils et blanc faut 2
non non convertis pas nos avantages
tonton convertit pas nos avantages pour
ses seins j'ai pas fait je dis aux
français si ce qui en français si ce
tour c'est un tu as les deux se tendre
sous des trois niveaux nous faire mentir
donc là il ya une idée typique pour les
leurs séquelles 2 kg légers 3 mais ça a
peut être possible à faire dans cette
structure à il veut y est ce qu'il veut
mais chercher quatre n'arrête
même ça abusé il veut faire g4 et g5 g4g
six fonds propres qui comprend jessen
cavaliers vous j'ai calé progressent 1
quand elle pu en toute aide mais je peux
pas de claquer manger 4 tu peux ça a
l'air d'être abusé mais bon voilà quand
je peut claquer angers 4 je claque quoi
j'ai de faire by ap à faire j'ai quatre
escales mais il va le faux 2 il aurait
dû faire au coude avant photo ça
ressemble vachement un parti contre des
gorilles en lin barcelone j'ai fait
genre y avait tour s'est vite pour cela
j'ai fait cavalier hcap talent et lisa f
ouais mais j'ai rien vu non plus j'ai
pas mal joué d'ailleurs il a fait bouger
si c'était pas mal et après il a fait
tomber vite 2006 et ben je pense qu'il
va faire caler h4 ces thématiques
si ça marche pour changer une pièce voix
banon pur isolé qu'il ya beaucoup de
pièces c'est trop de matériel effet
qu'ayyash quatre pattes en mode super
saiyan là tu devines tous les cours
hommage à connaît cette position ce wave
3 ouais c'est pas mal c'est un peu mieux
parce que des quatre marche pas et puis
on prend qu'il prend il faut prouver
cette fo et 5 pas mal aussi
5 pas mal aussi tour b a cédé 4
maintenant j'en prends quand même
j'écris proche de plage que je te prends
mais cette étude est fou prend je vais
faire un coup de cavaliers a4 avant
ouais je veux dire que j'ai un fou qui
est pas mal et si je fais tour c'est
yves que je te joue je te la joues fond
de court je fais cavalier e 2 ou
cavalières et cavaliers à 4 plutôt
habitué de ces après à tous à long terme
ouais il a fait des quatre peut-être sur
kelly à 4 il veut faire trois sets c'est
pourquoi il veut donner confiance ça se
regarde aussi ce genre de truc genre
vous prends mes sept tours à cette voie
10 ya pas trop de casse pour t'en fous
tu reviens f3 je te fais tour d'essai et
tout d'un coup je suis quand même assez
actif ouais c'est pas mal tu allais tour
bien placé et si la dame bien sûr c'est
peut-être juste double après je te coup
à mort meirieu skype pour iphone en est
plein de trucs qui traînent on est bien
à laisser la partie d'ailleurs la partie
à oued accord cavalia car il n'a pas
peur voilà rivard et c5
je préviens tout de suite j'aurais
jamais regardé un truc pareil mais je
vais pas faire du foot et huit la série
dc que sur cavaliers c5 je fais dame c7
et je te m'attends à ceux de ouais ouais
c'est pas mal mais fou et 8 je vais
faire je vais peut-être lâché un peu de
pression j'en reprends les quatre anti
ça ne flouent comprend les dames dame
bouge toi sûre d'elle des six jours et
g3 wave qui était ce un peu près
stabilisés après y'a taudis et des
touristes qui traîne non c'est pas toi
il le fait tous des vitres et ont fait
feu sur cette partie mais choisissez
celle d'hier on a nos dix minutes de ça
va pas durer un faux va bientôt
retrouver notre vrai niveau quoi et
attend il ya cavaliers doki qui menace
pèse aussi
non mais là tu m'as sauva la foudre en
d4 ça me paraît quasi forcée laurent
ouais j'ai l'impression aussi ce qui est
aussi dams et 7 et enfin oui il peut
varier père à plein de merde ça craint
sa cravate et était quasiment des
quasiment obligé de le prendre les
cavales ouais je pense aussi sinon
cavaliers de roy cher puisqu'il rêve
c'est pas pour des deux à la fin quand
la remontée deitermann
[Musique]
il veut faire valoir bon plaisir
il veut faire dame c6 laurent weil et là
il va pas se laisser marcher dessus
comme ça je peux pas faire un petit coup
de fouace est là pour essayer deux tu
peux cloud et j'ai plutôt pensé jean
retour des deux dames système des cas un
toit c'est de bien sur la terre au
soleil
ça y est c'est fini la chambre super
saiyan c'est fini et si ce fait dames 6
quand même je voulais faire d'amd 8 mai
vos bambins vite et je voulais te faire
tour ces 8es va pas du tout en fait
échanger autour d'eux pas mal solutions
à ces pratiques il a plus trop de temps
d'un essai trois tours c'est juste
heureux je te reconnais le retour en d2
du vin j'ai pas je vais jamais la perdre
cette position et noir n'ont ils font
face est très bien placé 1
il coupe un peu le cavale c'est chaud
l'on sait très chaud mais à tourbes et
devient joué le coup si acrobatique
peut-être tour des deux camps même tour
des nez de mls
soit il prend d'abord et il fait tour d2
mais j'aime pas le fait que le cavalier
surveillance écarte bien placé ouais
mais tu es là la tôle à tour la tour
blanche en f1 elle est quand même très
passif tu vois mais regardez il va il va
aller menacer f7 de son côté ouais si on
fouille besset qui a tout reprendre et
trois fonds pour un site en france devra
donc il faut c'est parce qu'il faut
faire x 4 cavaliers 4 c'est pas facile
cette position attention peut-être qu'un
manager karat j'ai envie de m'activer
hôtel kg quand j'anime active et de
faire tourner et on a eu ce matin j'ai
enfin bref droite et tour des huit pour
hachette qui l'épreuve s'est alors mais
celle ci va faire maintenant en fait
fait se croiser dès demain en effet il a
fait
il a protégé et maintenant je te laisser
wayne cette crise et 4 maintenant mais
fou c'est cette wave mais tu ne l'as pas
en changeant fait avec les c4 s'est tour
à tour ces trois voilà c'est très chaud
la haye les cavaliers comme ça ce
chéquier ça peut être ça peut être bien
sûr quel dessein qui va me faire ch pas
droit à cette crise est bien vu à ces
horribles
il ya encore un truc tactique ouais
maintenant il met la téléphonie à 8 h 4
d'abord il a fait h 4 d'avoir pour pas
laisser g5 un g6 à 5 tours à cette main
il est brian rich mais il réussit pas il
réussit pas à conclure quoi il n'est pas
assez fort je sais que j'ai un peu avec
mon rang ff4 d'abord de vraiment bon
mais là c'est sûr céline du coup c'est
horrible mais la vieille dame il allait
il a mis la pression dans cette partie
mais en fait tu voyages sais pas il ya
trois quatre parties comme ça qui était
chaude il ya une de nuit il ya eu deux
défaites
enfin ça se joue pas à grand chose mais
il ne réussit pas mal finir quoi voilà
cherche il n'est que temps devant depuis
en fait même s'ils avaient pas le pion
nom serait gagnon ses épaules que f 5
mai ouais ça c'est pas voilà il ya un
truc sur lequel on prend au f5 pour s3g
si je te laisse mater s'attaque le purin
5 c'est tout ça à trouver un accord
simplement autant près 1 autant pris
grave il avait calculé tu penses où il
est un peu de bol c'est bas
mais peut-être eu un peu de chance là
dessus comme non il postulait aussi
prieur de chance mais crise ou contre sa
façon son body language me rassure
ribéry revient peu ou b5
il rejoue pas tu vois savarières de tout
à l'heure c'est pas terrible mais bon on
voit que magnus vraiment là je regarde
un peu les caméras on voit que manu
c'est quand même pas à même si un écart
au score et tout c'est pas du tout la
même que contre soi
ouais bien sûr là il est vraiment à 100%
je pense aujourd'hui puis passer encore
de la marge mais j'ai l'impression que
voilà c'est une variante il ya vingt ans
que tout le monde joue en ce moment avec
les blancs il ya eu des matches car ils
akin d'un match qu'avec ligne karl scène
c'était quasiment l'album principal du
match 3 2 pouces 6 voilà on va voir il
ya eu une maxime qui avait deux parties
comme ça contre ardien ya quelques jours
au grand prix
ouais et très bien d'ailleurs max et
emme yeux n'ont d'ailleurs max était
très bien beaucoup mieux
il réussit à vif et keltra 2 le coup de
je sais plus qui enfin quoi ça ressemble
et là il pose de nouveaux problèmes des
nouvelles questions au noir mais ça n'a
pas l'air très inquiétant 3 non mais
c'est vraiment un gros débat théorique
toi non mais c'est impressionnant malgré
le score et tout ça ils ne lâchent rien
c'est typique banus human us a joué
plusieurs fois cette ligne donc il veut
voir ce que il sait que des trucs un peu
en tilt est susceptible de jouer ces
prépas ont du coup ils aient envie de
savoir qui l'a bien c'est pas mal ouais
il est peut-être mange
ouais ouais je trouve ça bien parce que
tu vois on voit au moins ce qui l'a
séduit montre ni les yeux un bond qui a
déjà été montrée mais il pense qu'il
peut y avoir davantage pour les blancs
ce dont j'étais pas convaincu très
honnêtement
donc tu à rechercher un là je vais
rechercher peut-être ou pas d'air et là
il ya eu un problème pour les norias de
questions donc soit tu prends ces quatre
soit tu protèges champions bessin un
journal b cet anneau il est protégé en
fait depuis en bessin qu'est ce que je
raconte
tu peux quand même pas comme ça qu'il
est si tu as envie ouais mais si pendant
ces 4 tu vois sur le long terme je
réussis à jouer de beyssac avec des
blancs et j'aurais pu repasser
tu auras le courant aux 7 qui est pas
terrible c'est seul problème de la
position nord c'est une fois en sept
il ya peut-être des a5 qui marche ou pas
parfois j'essaie dans ce type de
structure yade et ça ça marche c'est une
très mauvaise nouvelle pour les blancs
et albion b46 reste en l'air assez sa
pure prendrait ça qui fait qu'on met 4
mai en france jusqu'à la production
français 6 intermedia oui mais je crois
qu'il va me prendre et roy ont marqué
dès 5 heures et tous les jours je passe
et où l'on a pu voir mes et mais j'ai
pas le temps de faire ses 5 ce qui a des
quatre ici et il ya je pense que ça va
en fait présent assez bien vu ça va ce
liquide et tu vois et prend des 5 et
prendrait 5 tu prends des cinq duos ou
prends mes 4 je te fais un coup de
tomber un bon mais voilà news ouais
peut-être une légère légère pression
pour les blancs mais même pas en fait si
tu fais c'est prendre et ça je vais
faire vous promet 4 mais si federer
murray 5
je fais faire dame prend puis on prend
un tour à des huit choix parce que si je
faisais il faut prendre mais qu'as tu
faisais furent bien situé si tu fais mal
un retour à des 8 tu peux peut-être
faire tourrades évident qu on prend b5
puis on prend b5 tour prend à 8 tours
prend huit fosses et ce alors je te paie
tout autour ad oui tu seras à tour à des
mutuelles ouais c'est bien vu laurent
mellotron tour allait me très bien vu
laurent et tous rêvent des huit mois il
y aurait eu né de l'idée mais tour à des
ouais
c'est la partie donc là peut-être
faction 39 repos pour tirer manul c'est
mon truc en fait tu vois ce que je fais
donc pour tirer value j'arrive des
complications tactique c'est un peu
moins un peu moins bien mais et si
j'essaye de faire plus on prend puis on
prend et tour à 7
je vous promets 4 et tours b 1-1 pas mal
avec cette affair tu reprends b5 et de
bas après ça pas être grand chose mais
si si quand même j'ai perdu la partie
parce que devine quoi j'ai été inactif
pendant rien mais tu as eu le temps
passe vite non pas charger impression
alors c'est fou hein
belle séquence quand tu vois des baux
échec de toute façon ça passe vite
ouais moi j'adore ces matches c'est vrai
qu'en s'ennuie on s'ennuie pas donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il a fait tout
ravisseurs finalement je sais pas ça pas
mal ce qu'ont proposé avec le prix
freestyle x 7 mai toi c'est que tu te
faisais fois ci ça leur apprendra à
m'excuser pouces et 5 et des six avec
mon jeu n'est pas alors où en tour assez
de tours fc 8ème et on a fait je voulais
faire le seulement d'après je laissais
avec tours c'est un tour c 'est bref ça
être qu'enfin je m'active et
m'apprennent a dû rater quelque chose
pas sûr mais probable alors la poussée
sauf que là il me propose de la en gros
ouais bah alors enfin il a raison parce
que tu vois ça craint un peu parce que
tu es le plus repris 3 est faible il
alla il a la chance kelman du couloir ça
va lui permettre de peut-être fait
retour à cinq là par contre b4g 4ème
mais bon au moins ce que tu auras 5e
finale tout de suite bkw à b5 une case
et on est chargé
ouais c'est ça m6 sera f1 et puis vont
échanger et puis ils vont fumer le
calumet de la paix voilà donc un rôle à
jouer
non non
non arrêter les mecs
oui la joie et chaud qu'à proposer mieux
eia ils voyaient mais c'est peut-être le
petit jeu psychologique
genre tu es obligé de proposer nul c'est
toi qui es tu vois ce que le chronomètre
tourne
ouais mais là il va y joue pas la montre
non mais j'ai reparlé psychologiquement
tu es obligé de faceo blanc de proposer
nul parce que si tu n'as pas du tout
intérêt à la jouer pendant 10 minutes
quoi oui bien sûr nation on sait qu'ils
jouent des six si elle me marie prend
des voix divine au score et obligés de
parce qu'il va répéter son âge quatre
noms ah ben non c'est plutôt temps mais
h 4 sur 6 ouais mais balancer h4 quand
même laurent et il l'a fait il a fait il
l'a fait dans une autre version dire que
ça fait sérieux optique ou consiste en
quoi ouais moi j'aime bien parfois
changer la structure 6,5 fois c'est ce
que j'allais bien là j'ai toujours
l'impression mais les noirs font rire ou
pas du tout je comprends rien en fait je
sais pas ce que veulent les blancs
j'aime voyager de fait rage 6 août au 6
septembre pour être que positif tu vois
j'ai l'impression qu'à 3 becker à trois
mais quatre voitures gesticuler la dame
mais qui fait rien de spécial alors
qu'avec les noirs direct à un plan plus
clair à chis f5 wave systems 17 f 5 des
6 février tous les pocatois très facile
à jouer je sais pas ce qu'il fait limbé
ça n'est pas très impressionnant cabine
à l'ouverture de banques mais tu sais il
ya un truc marrant c'est quand on
regarde les matchs d'hikaru c'est
exactement la même chose
d'accord et il gagne à chaque fois fin
en fait le seul qui a maté hikaru
jusqu'à maintenant c'est magnus
mais bon j'ai eu comme quand caruana
hills et kf3 b3 tout est parti oui ils
ont complètement whisky un fou
complètement beaucoup plus qu en fait
beaucoup plus que ma musique et il te
dit de toute façon je suis plus fort que
toi je vais te battre et dans toutes les
positions
ouais c'est ça
en fait le match contre maxime c'est
très chaud il y avait beaucoup destin
diène et tout ça mais malheureusement
max avait perdu mais c'est un match très
très chaud devoir donc je raconte
n'importe quoi c'est gênant mais fun fun
si je me rappelle match de maximy jeu 25
août théorie avec un autre type j'ai pu
qui s'était messei cas où je pense oui
oui je suis amusé à jouer 25 août
théorie et jouer la finale
il y avait des finales de berlinoises y
avait beaucoup de matchs dorff c'était
ça va envoyer du lourd donc là ils
essaient de faire son plan les dames
mais il a réussi encore alors je te fais
food et 2 à 4 à 5 tomber un mois ça se
passe là où j'ai envie que ça se passe
finalement il n'y a pas eu de f5
c'est fou quoi c'est chiant mais
maintenant il est toujours question à la
légère oublie date à laquelle la qualité
tombe il avait pas vu notre mini est ce
que ça va suffire
c'est si c'est un bon départ déjà et
après il est à 4 6 4 il va faire il va
faire ses preuves et 5 et des deux qui
étaient 4 à 4 à 5
et puis il va gagner en prétendant qu'il
avait tout vu non mais c'est
insupportable si gagner ça reste quand
même une qualité de plus ouais mais les
la position affirmée non c'est pas c'est
pas dramatique
tu penses qu objectivement les peut-être
des 900 milliards il ya des chances
comme parce que je vais tout changer en
des 5 ans mangeait très attaquées te
pousser suffisamment le délai si on peut
pas faire [ __ ] en débats francs 2,5
directement a pas forcément besoin mais
je alors oui il faut le forcer à prendre
du plan c à 5 y avait pas mal vu en fait
j'avais pas vu du tout reprend 3
jusqu'au camp des saints et ce n'est pas
lui qui avait cloué
en fait j'ai rien vu mais tu vois je
suis chaud quoi mais peut-être tour à
cette dame à 8 maintenant je sais pas je
suis lancé un défi à libye
pour je pronostique le coup non je suis
meilleur que toi mais on essaye de ne
pas avec l'habitude on essaye de pas ces
quatre super j'adore ce court l'idée
était surpris on prend ces 4 kgs c-50
tempo brouette de titan simplifier la la
transition mais là ils perdent des six
mais il s'est pris un chip haut à lui
aussi d'un b 3 qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire il veut claquer rbk probablement
est ce que tu veux faire de nom mais il
s'écria un chip où il n'avait pas du
tout reprend à trois fouilles b4y
l'avais pas vu il joue viril et
matériaux il est mieux là il est
nettement mieux si peu après être que
c'est mieux que l'autre position et la
qualité de plus je pense pas mais d'un
point de vue pratique c'est peut-être
mieux ça d'ailleurs d'impôt objectif
c'est mieux l'autre c'est sûr mais d'un
point de vue pratique c'est pas sûr
ouais j'ai assez d'accord et puis comme
il avait réuni deux mois bon je sais
plus j'ai j'ai un peu honte à chaque
fois de préciser le temps en fait il
faut être quatre deux heures et demie de
moins dans cette partie en train
d'établir un nouveau record
donc là qu'il faut qu'ils essayent de
pousser aux quatre anneaux ans dans de
bonnes conditions il dame et oui
aujourd'hui final c'est la question
posée en plus mais j'ai pas le thème à
nyons et 4 soit très fort là laurent way
exact il avait fait n'importe quoi a
great shot y va fort quand même
non c'était vraiment de la merde
franchement non on n'a pas vu c'était
pas d'accord et oui il ay lâchera rien
tous les cadres restent bas et même
quand ils donnent ni catéchisme pas
derrière moi j'essaie hikaru en plus
fort en fait c'est bien ce que gagner
une partie en fait c'est ça va être
compliqué moi quand je fais des beats
avec lui moi c'est plus et maintenant
c'est nous on fait de moins en moins je
perds trop et je fais beaucoup de nuls
en fait beaucoup de nuls je fais des
nuls quoi mais gagner une partie s'est
très
compliqué ce qui te pose des problèmes
tout le temps rien à faire être bien
c'est pas le problème tient à marseille
mais gagner une partie
ça c'est une autre une autre paire
dollar à qui je dis tu quoi j'étais
vraiment pas loin des abers et et à un
coude a gagné moi j'étais un coup bref
c'est un coup ou des quatre est garant
du manant daïra biarritz à quelqu'un il
va encore la perle ou quoi non mais en
fait tu veux faire [ __ ] en f2 dans
trois champs c'est le seul coup à et
peut-être il va falloir te faire un
cavalier f2 bien senti avec au minimum
perpète
mais s'il y avoir mieux que perpète non
il y aura pas mal de pertes est est-ce
qu'il peut pas faire x 7
c'est la vraie question comme ça il peut
répéter white beauville non mais je
crois qu'il a pas mieux
toutefois cette fois c'est pourquoi
ailleurs le caillou 3 et f1 n'en joue
pas je tenterai de fausses factures
échec quand même fo prend tout reprend
et roger 7
alors il a fait tous ok je voyais les
détours ses échecs et ce soir là sous le
fouet
mais bon c'est peut-être là il ya le
score à wickham restons après chaque
partie des châteaux clos baillie
discutent sous les caméras mais bon
enfin je sais pas a jugé enfin je trouve
que ça pas énorme intérêt j'ai peur là
le stream il est bien on a bien notre
rythme mais j'ai peur que ça coupe tu
vois d'accord et quand j'écoute ses
toiles à l'épaule pas ça non mais enfin
on peut le faire à tout moment quoi mais
je me dis c'est un peu dommage qu'on est
bien dans le match nous dans les
commentaires aussi si sa coupe c'est un
peu nous couper tu vois bon alors et
d'orge d'accord alors que finalement je
me répète un peu mais tu mates un match
de tennis eu mal fait un match de foot
tu n'as pas les commentateurs sur les
sur l'écran quoi bien sûr que non mais
je suis d'accord mais bon
si on peut tout voir tu vois les gens
c'est ça mais bon c'est la mode avec le
monde a envie de tout voir quoi ya des
caméras partout et donc là il a joué
espagnol des trois encore il n'a pas
fait b5 et la ligne qui les a qui jouent
d'habitude il a joué décidiez plus
modeste voix mais qui est sûr c'est
jouable
c'est jouable mais pas très j'aime pas
trop aller fous ces deux g4 qui a valu
aux trois quarts élèves saint calais
laurent il faut fonds envoyés là bas il
est obligé de garder les fous parce que
il a plu espaces dont il est un des
footings par les casques blancs et à
faire ces cinq bessac tu vois un petit
coup de hache 6 d'abord mais sur des
quatre je me remets un coupé qui va
faire dans une mairie un couple est
d'ailleurs 9,13 à son tour c'est ça que
j'aurais pu mettre ma main à couper
tu le sentais wen lors ses cinq buts
s'accéler plein d'hormones tu vois dams
et 7 trois des huit ça joue au camas
c'est à ce cas c'est automatique
c'est les plans lambda denis d'espagnol
c'est plutôt à la pour les blancs c'est
pas c'est pas mais bon c'est pas au
scandale non plus pour pour les noirs
par mon évier jabr attaque 38 qui fait
une belle analogie dans le chat qui
écrit carlson à chaque partie c'est
comme un monstre à mille têtes
à chaque fois que tu en coupe une y en a
une autre qui repousse mais c'est ça en
fait tout à fait fait ça exactement ça
mais il perd plus déjà comme il ya eu
deux nuls à banias ne regarde d'affilée
4 d'affiner et afficher la carte b4
alors sa b4 ces étranges doit
normalement tu rajoutes pas comme ça tu
avais vu de la partie contre contre
caruana a line of my way gb j'ai vu je
joue et je jouais à potable mais n'était
pas loin dans cet espagnol a annoncé pas
bien où il a fait g4 qu'il grossit des
jets 4 kg 3
mais c'est fou il a gagné hyper facile
finalement n'ai-je pas à quoi ça me
faisait penser cette partition pas
trouvé le truc en b4 et tout ça m'a fait
penser à cette partie tout d'un coup il
a réussi à le bas et c'était
impressionnant
j'ai vécu moi je vais contre nantes ce
jour-là ferrer en 8e en 8 es
je jouais chéquier trois contrats normes
moi j'ai perdu mais j'étais vraiment
j'ai vu en direct
j'étais bien d'ailleurs suffit pas non
mais j'ai beaucoup rigolé avec la nul
2-2 cramique contre lawrence trent je me
suis ok là quand même
ouais c'est tout c'est d'apprendre à
rigoler on se demandait si on n'a jamais
autant parlé d'une nulle dans un tournoi
open table 33,6
c'est la partie ssd roule table trahi la
paix il a fait 45 tweet posté petit
château de sa partie non mais c'est
génial
ces plaisirs pour lawrence que c'est un
mec cool ouais alors oui mais j'aime
beaucoup
puis croit en plus j'adore il joue les
tournois et tout ça non mais juge me dit
pour un mec comme cram ni se retrouver
table 30 contes retrait n'était pas
gagné enfin c'est dur pour les communes
commencent enfin à ce débat d'égalité
quand même ex champion du monde d'échecs
tu te retrouves contre contre un
commentateur table 30 taper raid en
garde un livret a voit il le connaît pas
ce qu'il a vu commenté et tout ça oui ça
y est tu analyses et il ya du réfugié il
a dû réfuter 50 fois tu vas y aller non
mais c'est ça que les parents c'est que
j'ai passé comme si tu fais un foot et
que tu te fais des dribbles et par
paganelli coiffage malpagat et et jordan
tout avant mais bon quand même quoi
voilà c'est très sacrifier la qualité
pas non mais là les options bien laurent
et pensons les bears ont bien mal et
blanc sont gagnants mais trois je prends
un raté blanc sony au présent ou même
peut-être à 5 3 je crois que ça a l'air
bidons sont sapés fils yonatan il a une
qualité absurde mais c'est de la merde
c'est toujours la même question tu vas
s'il fouetter en v6 battu directeur sait
pas si clair à mettre fin à la fuite
du coup ça donne pas envie là on
refusait de faire à 5 j'étais obligé à
faire du tour à 8 puis après je te
plante raid u15 a du coup il fait fou
c'est fou c'est vite fois-ci s'il va
bloquer ce plan-là au passage tout en
attaquant mont fuji et est obligé de
améliorera le cavalier qui m'arrive
f5 faut faire à 5 alors en a 5 x 6 km 5
qui fait mais il va manquer cesser les
karatékas ouais non c'est dangereux
c'est chiant j'en peux plus je n'en
pensais je vais d'options ouais je
pensais que ça bien à temps mais tu te
réveilles le fou quand même temps en a
dans le bras
ce serait pas une guerre qui viennent
faire là bas il vient de faire une tête
très bizarre la guiguette schouppe ouais
il a raté la d61 sur mer très mécontents
quoi on va voir s'il a de la chance tour
alors je crois qu'il ya eu 17 à william
mg simple d'un an d'âge et celle de vos
trois littorales qui essayent chekwa
fait peut-être c5v ces cinq des six quoi
et je te contre attaque sur f7 de
l'autre côté
non c'est simple je fais qu'elle prend
c'est ça c'est toujours prouver je
t'attaque le four b3 je vais faire b3
donc c'est très compliqué ici pour les
pour les verts mais je a partout raveurs
auquel je l'espère tout le programme
tout en france et 8,1 oui bien sûr c'est
toujours une tour france et 8
et moi je te pousse ses pions blancs
riches de pouce le pion à en fait je te
fais a5 a6 a7 a8 peut-être par exemple
café tour 1 mais oui ok peut-être un peu
le parquet dit c'est toi ça il peut
claquer maintenant et il aura cavaliers
la mnef [ __ ] pardon pour le langage
mais c'est juste que laurent là ça va
trop loin
ça doit faire quoi là j'ai obligé de
prendre 5 je voulais donner la dame ça
marchait pas du tout ça combiné à temps
et si tu fais dame b 8 mb 8 je vais te
faire ou six ouais donc j'ai dû faire
tout reprendre à huit jours des cailloux
c'est un oui mais attend il a récupéré
deux tours
non c'est pas clair c'est pas clair sauf
si elle décide qui marche i a décidé ça
qui marche
tu vois ça veut dire c'est chaud laurent
et je vois ce que tu veux tu être très
chaud plus à laurent j'en peux plus mais
vaut faire des six way est comme ça il a
triché ou f4 ont fessé 5 on en voit tous
allés sacha il a l'air fou tu es à la
hâte en à quai dès 3g pas que les
progressistes d'am-dam jamais à faire
cavalier ces cinq caisses et cinq de ses
six évoluent option c'était compliqué ça
joue au tempo tout peut arriver
voilà j'en peux plus ah c'est pas mal ce
qu'il y avait encore je vais te faire
[ __ ] un obstacle d'un problème ça que
je prends des six mais j'aurais
peut-être non mais attends il charrie la
rive 5 ça il a perdu et la peur du krill
bas il doit être foutu non mais il y
aura des c2 tu vois oui oui je vois
c'est fini j'ai bien peur ces deux
genres france et 2 français 2 6 d'amd de
b3 à b2 et dames enfin faire dame prend
des cadres n'avaient pas fou près fanon
mais le truc c'est que l'âme des 5
allez faut peut-être il a calculé cette
variante en fait il ya cv ac2a il fait
tourner en conclusion ouais ça bien joué
bravo grosse partie s'est terminée la
haye fait ces deux c'est fini ouais
quelle horreur laurent wayne bridge qui
n'en peut plus ah c'était compliqué hein
c'était une partie très classe
franchement il est écoeuré à ce jour
encore darleux dans le dans les
dernières secondes à chaque fois il
s'est surtout les dernières secondes
pour get choc c'est aussi un problème
vois tu peux pas jouer avec 10 secondes
en permanence contre le non mais c'est
magnifique ce qu'on voit mais c'est bien
c'est même avec une caille t'imagines
laurent quand même le niveau du mec là
dedans c'est très impressionnant
voilà maintenant il a dit je crois que
savoir partie oui je d'écarter voulait
probablement voir autre chose
ce que great choc pardon avait préparé
c'est probablement pas ça mais vu le
score il me reste aliens pour essayer de
remonter
voilà il joue elle se prend des cas tu
cries de saintes et bien joué quatre
fous 3 3 ou h3 il va faire trois
prisonniers si ça marche d'ailleurs oui
il faut trois bons c'est assez
confortable ça normalement pour les
blancs j'aurais aimé donner le centre
tout de suite alors tu fais rien je te
fais dam des deux tours à d un tour et
ferons à chaque fois que je connais mes
cours voilà les dessins qui accueille
français titan demain ça c'est sûr c'est
pas marché c'est une position théorique
tant que c'est son supermarché pour les
noirs je crois que c'est le cap le coup
la maigrichonne bien ça se voit que la
sur la caméra il est de plus en plus bas
y ait de moins en moins cadrée et c'est
de plus en plus sombre abs boursault à
la fin envoyer plus du tout alors on les
voit de moins en moins tu as
l'impression qu'ils coulent à chaque
fois mais la grille jusqu'à lui a fait
mal la dernière mais je crois que
c'était f4 secours en fait oui de me
prendre et vite mais ils peuvent alors
être cardiaque et 17 talent voilà c'est
ça la pointe c2pay changeur des huit de
jouer quatre fois sur kyle 17 à food et
4 et je crois que c'est assez chiant
pour les hawks étaient répartis sur ça
mais enfin pour l'heure le seul
maintenant qui peut battre on a vu tout
le monde et le ce dernier qui ont envie
de voir face à carl scène c'est cariat
qui n'en fait adapté je vois que tu es
libre laddh je peux dire à mes fans
veulent a donc sonné le résultat s'est
pas fait c'est pas intéressant après la
scission d'accor mais c'est pas un
terrain après fin tu vois je ne veux pas
assez assisté à l'exécution magnus ça ne
m'intéresse pas un kayak in tu crois en
blitz balle et surtout le nombre de
blitz quand même un quart yakine away la
distance est trop longue
je crois que là mais il a été
impressionnant car yakine dans les
matches précédents laurent va écraser
les pommiers à venir ja écrasé c'était
incroyable j'avais parié sur des pour
machines comme un fish et alors il s'est
mêlé 6 des dépôts machine m'a vraiment
déçu
franchement mais tu sais il avait écrasé
meilleur qui ait pas quand même battu
par nancy ni succès comme si tu dis les
peaux machine à écraser fasciné tu sais
pas c'est pas la même classe de joueurs
non je sais mais championnat doublettes
là on est d'accord mais tu vois en fait
son match contre meyer en compte pas non
au kenya nous reste contre les polonais
9 à la sortie du 5q sterger plus d'une
heure mais niveau n'est pas aussi les
antilles toi il n'y a pas pris
sérieusement en ce match et là cavalier
5 très bon coup ouais parce qu'il menace
et il menace est là et il est encore
bien getxo marocaine une pièce de plus
ouais matin il ya la fameuse liste rim
tu vois elf quatre sacs les blancs son
nom wii vont après tu as raison fin
ouais faut être quatre cinq ou 2d et les
pièces vont finalement c'est de la merde
je veux le dire clairement et à haute
voix la rocqué les blancs sont gagnants
dont les mots soit on gagne en fait oui
tu as tout à fait raison je commentais
très mal cette partie et heureusement
que tu nous remet dans le bain c'est
qu'on peut pas faire genre x 4 avec
l'idée de te faire sur pions prend 1,5
fou prend d un tour prendrait un temps
de 8
ouais c'est possible mais c'est toujours
mieux pour les pour les noirs mais je
pense pas que ce soit le truc le plus
propre
tu vois à vue de nez mais ça trouve il
s'est fracassé plus pratique
peut-être mais est ce que tu es sûr que
cette finale elle est gagnante après non
mais tu sais moi car la scène je suis
très heureux quoi ça me suffit mais
voilà il a fait cas des quatre cas mais
garde la pièce il a pas compris les dr
passé est lié sa vallée d'elah d'huy a
montré la grave coiffage dire par là il
salua pas suffi quoi ton c'est la miilos
mais c'est dur à jouer ça avec les noirs
laurent c'est bien belle soeur foutu
d'ailleurs si tu peux vraiment la perdre
genre tu donnes en bas il a perdu il
apparut des filles 1 il va se rendre dès
six fours bessette et adieu quoi ouais
alors des siècles et prend des six ouais
c'est légère combinaison mais ouais non
c'est pas facile non mais honnêtement
non mais je ne plaisante pas et
l'évaluation il faut des vrais choix
curieux d'ailleurs devant lui l'évasion
de drogue ou qu'elle ait des six ça peut
faire très mal
mais il est quand même très
impressionnant le muscle c'est vraiment
un bestiau même là ils lâchent pas t'as
vu un caïd et 5 et tout ça c'est pas mal
là jamais un centimètre il n'aime pas ça
mais celle là va être dur à la roma je
sais pas quoi penser de ce truc
objectivement oui pas objectivement n'at
on sait que tu que tu comprends la
position après objectivement sur
beaucoup plus difficile en fait à
comprendre
ouais ce que c'est vraiment wen ont
quand même gagné face mais c'est
tellement pas évident mais surtout
psychologiquement quand tu t'es fait
arnaquer quand tu t'es fait prêt à tout
mais attention tu prends un super
récompense ses filles tout simplement
comme vers des partis n'ont d'ailleurs
d'un record de tours à se passe mal ben
voila tu perds la confiance tu recalcul
des lignes on l'a tous vécu mais il
conclut manu their à tout le monde avec
us l'un d'eux tu vois de faire des
gaffes et après évidemment un truc un
peu plus que d'habitude qui passent du
temps je trouve en taille de rater une
nouvelle gaffe arrive
et voilà robin et ça je pense que c'est
plus gagné en fait déjà pour les blancs
oui je pense que ces schémas pas c'était
vraiment gagnant gagnant un moment donné
mais ça je pense qu objectivement c'est
sûr c'est pas des nains moi je dirais
quand même que je te fais plus confiance
à toi que je ne me fais confiance si tu
veux donc c'est ouais c'est à quelqu'un
qui sait c'est toi moi je vois bien ce
nom je sais pas mais y'a pas aussi cela
puis on prend fou prend 1,6 mais tu veux
pas reprendre je te fais 17 et des huit
dames
ouais j'ai dû perdre et je peux te faire
[ __ ] quatre échecs ou prendre froid
aussi rim a joué plus de 3,8
c'est pas énorme et franchement saigne
c'est entre les deux ce genre de truc tu
vois si tu sais jamais complètement cité
gagner ou pas avec les noirs métal
échéance clairement que tu vois il ay va
regrouper à faire qu'à g7
aussi en séries le foin le foot case
noire pour les pour les noirs et quand
même pas débattre après j'hesite voit
par exemple n'est pas très actif
bref tu peux plus sortir petit qui joue
pour gagner ma nuit et ça on va
directement faire tu as est en fait car
j'avais en fait tu perds plus là
j'essaye tout j'essaie c'est tout autant
foot recasement à il sort plus voyez
quand murray bat c'est fini ouais j'sais
pas quoi y afficher alors est ce qui s
qui non mais il cherche à gagner en fait
quand même pas gagné wen ont ils fait
j'ai ça vous dit pourquoi ne pas figer
5e c'est ce qu'il a pensé qu'ils avaient
des coups d'attentats près qui se
faisait rentrer par le cabba fin je vois
pas trop comment mais peut-être
peut-être si blizzard jacopin g7 comme
ça dans l'antre peut pas gagner mais là
maintenant évidemment c'est beaucoup
plus chaud ou là il ya de données
arrêtées mais il veut récupérer mes
meilleurs querelle qui est toujours en
vie donc c'est dangereux ouaip il a
estimé le fou assez compliquée j'en vois
c'est chaud mais il a des chances il ya
des chansons avec la règle de temps et
s'est passé avant
je dirais que ses chances sont assez
réduites mais ouais mais peut-être
pouvoir faire roi des cette affaire fois
fuite ou fou machin roi 17 et bah ça va
être nul quand même peut-être fou d un
échec aussi c'est pas un simple
engagement là et je cours c'est chaud
puisque attend si je fais pousser 6 et
c'est chaud quand même il doit regarder
faisait six cas au lycée cisson vraiment
il fait ça je comprends je comprends
plus rien pourquoi il n'a pas pris un
air 4 est pris en d6 amy va tomber il va
tomber
je sens qu'il va la perdre en fait
impossible
bon ok 2 ok ça c'est bien pour lui que
ce que c'est comme ça armée bon ok on
fermait et cruel
wen ont une partie non c'était pas si
clair il avait encore encore une fois il
a pris une bonne chance pratique elle
vaincu sur sacrifiant c'est cette pièce
pour les deux pions passé c'est un peu
faire raser dans l'ouverture pour cela
il va faire quoi même bien fait chier
y'a pas réfléchir un bon il va pas
répéter qu est ce qui peut faire ou on
bizarre de prendre une seconde ici c'est
quand même un peu étrange
non mais il prend vraiment des bonnes
chances se pratique à chaque fois aïe
les parties les plus il est plus caméra
là il est simplement il et j'ai pas il
est il absent là d'accord
d'où la narbonnaise devant les caméras
ouais enfin nous en même temps si on ne
voit pas c'est pas grave non mais là les
joueurs on voit qu'un scène est absent
fait en voix qui a aligné plus quoi
d'accord moi j'ai pas en fait les
caméras mais bon oui je me fais
confiance
ouais je joue talent et comprend pas il
en pls baïla dieu avoir une envie
pressante un genre pas d'autre
explication
[Musique]
il remet son casque est reparti il ya
partie est rien fait il a pris le pion
et oui c'est qu'il ya passé deux breaks
franchement pour les joueurs c'est dur
un bain pour tout le monde en fait un
ouais ouais non franchement ce serait
pour paul bret mais en fait l'année
dernière et derek de cinq minutes à
chaque fois entre les trucs et la marie
font des vrais contre 2 3 minutes et
franchement je
je comprends pas ce changement je
trouvais que le break de cinq minutes
c'était bien au contraire la figure toi
c'est la partie comme cris ciocca
reykjavik au championnat objets jouets
fouet 5,2 kg 6 tailles perdu et ils
jouent kg 6 fawcett qui est aussi un
plan complètement thématique allennois
allez lire lors de coups il est pas mal
pour les énormément parce que c'est la
mauvaise tour qui en des 28 mai à faire
aussi tête a forcé le renoir à venir sur
les droits à la vie normale va verser 3
s'est vite voilà donc c'est pour ça que
tu connais chez tu mets l'amour et ce
tour pour forcer le roi noir et au pire
parfois les blancs et me font tout re 1
et tours à d un dieu tellement bon là
normalement on fait des coups comme ces
captures voix est ce que tu penses que
ça peut le temps dans cette partie peut
influer négativement m il a choisi de
jouer la finale je vois pas ce qu'il
connaît bien les plans qu'elles plus
facile à jouer donc en fait il a fait
exprès de choisir à venir l'écouter
c'est mieux de ces lieux de belles autos
l'aide que d'attendre non c'est un choix
après un choix mais bon il ya de la
vence il a perdu deux minutes car les f4
empêcher cahill et 5 et le cavaliere
aussi s'est toujours très bien passé
donc là il n'y a pas de problème dans la
loire pour les voir j'ai déjà les
sorties aussi se parjurer d'uccle il
aimait car il prend aussi sa pas l'air
du tout de marché je vais faire avec eux
aussi sympa mais si ça il veut je
comprends pas trop lent fait
l'enchaînement ce qu'il veut faire du
cahier des seuls cabello cinq voix il te
prendre à la gorge des voix hélas si on
fait cap bep 5 avec les morts et près de
600 km
ouais je vais faire ainsi fait il a
pensé qu'ils allaient encaisser plus
facilement le pire ils menacent aussi
francis maintenant ouais probablement
remplir la case f7 pour le roi ouais
c'est ce qui va faire une réussite
et il va le prendre c'est sûr maintenant
wife c'est vrai ou faux dès 6h faut
calculer un peu non mais s'est mis dans
la peau on pourrait bien alors il peut
rien à voir là c'est pas possible c'est
ce voile ça mange pas quoi non c'est
vraiment bidon il s'est enfin c'est
pipeau pipeau
mais oui mais il n'est pas toi une fois
que tu joues qualiac 4 et ils échangent
les cavaliers est affaire de fous c'est
pas bon pour les blancs et si calais
vient aussi c'est vraiment grave pour
les nerfs donc il essayait ceci ce qui
est thématique des seuils de ces seuils
d'embrouillés un peu mais c'est ça
marche pas du tout là dans cette
position mois il m'avait battu justement
avec avis qu'il ait réussi dans cette
partie et ça marchait très bien
c'est donc tu vois c'est pas nourri oui
non mais je comprendrais mais donc
contre toi ça passe contre césar des
meilleurs conditions là quand même tour
cet endroit il fit tout simplement les
cavaliers et le roi reste attaqué
heynckes a en fait je viens de
m'apercevoir que le fou ces huit venait
se réveiller occupe une pièce c'est
terminé il va abandonner robuste et du
3e ligne finalement ils peuvent être
faits retour 4 encore il fait tour 4 est
heureux quelques épreuves trois
patronnes moins deux voire trois parce
que oui qu'en septembre un choix pour
preuve cette attaque la tour h 3 et 6 7
2 non j'ai pas pouvoir le prendre
meilleurs atours d2 of avancer une
boucherie qu'est ce qui nous fait
pourquoi il fait bon et abandonnés parce
commence à faire cher là + 7 us and hell
un ouais non plus 6 + 6 pardon je pense
j'ai pas vu que la partie était déjà
comptabilisés
d'accord il se passe quoi là du coup
je sais pas ils doivent rejouer une
partie alors c'est peut-être j'ai pas vu
s'élargir random c'est ça non pas encore
encore d'accord c'est dans ce sens là
quand on a une autre discussion hier je
disais le format tuner le format
vraiment bien parce qu'il favorise le
plus fort et je disais oui mais c'est
peut-être ça favorise peut-être même
trop le favori en fait parce que du coup
vraiment enfin tu as l'impression que le
plus fort gagne tout le temps qu à ce
jeu là ouais mais c'est passé non mais
c'est bien mais d'un autre côté tu as
patate a presque l'impression que tu as
plus le le côté inattendu du sport
quattro en option si tu es plus fort il
ya tellement de partie et tout ça que
bon noyau c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
oui l'année dernière je vous rappelle il
y avait eu aucune surprise p 0 01 en
fait la première surprise c'était même
pas une vraie surprise c'est un match
très serré et c'était gris tout qui
battait maxime choix des mixtes et une
surprise parce qu'obligés plus quoi mais
bon c'est un mail à 50 50
maxime contre gries tout c'est 50 50
je pense que maxime peu de vent qu'elle
ne s'est pas mais bon peut-être s'éduque
55,45 j'en sais rien c'est oui match
toute façon mais non ça je vois peu ça
joue un peu quand j'ai 50 50 c'est
pourquoi oui pour pas faire de comptes
d'apothicaire mais tu vois c'est comme
dans l'es10 risso dans les pays riches
aux kiwis c'est à dire par là on y
produit 50 50 mais dès que tu as un mec
qui est juste au dessus je sais pas tu
mets mvl contre contre guiry déjà je
pense que c'est face à lens est déjà
massacre avec ça c'est sûr et en fait
pourtant n'y a pas une si grande
différence verdict à une petite
différence est que tu sors du 60/40 tu
te fais défoncer ouais ouais bon là pour
l'instant le score est ce que tu veux et
je sais pas si ça reflète vraiment la
physionomie du match mais après les
propos que tu vois que tous les mérites
toujours bon quand il se bat il va mieux
il l'impression que ouais voilà ça
contient peu de temps de y arriver non
mais
résultat les tunnels ouais ouais bon la
dernière seconde c'est quand même
tellement le pantin ouais mais en ce qui
ce qui est impressionnant c'est que
great food dans les dernières secondes
c'est un monstre
ouais donc tu imagines lamont street u2
de magnus quoi fin ça veut dire que
magnus et je passe sangoku quoi donc
voir là une sicilienne classique
je sais pas ce qu'il va faire et que ça
va manger trois mois je le sens que
l'acquéreur qui a rallié des 5 assez
rapidement c'est pas possible tu chantes
5 ha et des cinq puis on prend des cinq
puis on prend des cinq dames prend des 5
pour prendre cette es tu peux pas
prendre dans des cases que je te prends
à fiat et je reprends des quatre mois
dans l'esprit ouais ce genre de truc
genre de trucs mais je le sens de
claquer bientôt d'un mètre troc et six
mois j'aurais plutôt vu chômage trois
ans fait pour me laisser des pourpres et
voilà pour menacer fou prend 1,6 et 2,5
et tu vois ici petit c'est obligé de
toucher un pion du rock et pas très
content mais je fais haschich peut-être
te refaire dame g3 ouais tu vois je vois
si j'ai quatre le classique ouais en
plus possible d'ailleurs
ouais j'y crois pas mais en tout cas
c'est c'est le moment ou jamais après je
crois pas parce que quand tu crois que
ça qui trouvera d'un match un match qui
sera un peu embêtant ouais mais tu es
dans l'esprit à fond ouais c'est comme
ça que nous apportent non en fait c'est
ça c'est qu'en fait même la défaite est
quelque part une victoire pour toi après
sa fin tant l'adversaire ne peut plus
rien faire en fait même si lui même
s'était toujours pas content de la
partie quoi qu'il arrive
oui ben oui non mais même fin c'est ce
que je dis aux gens quand il vit quand
vous jouez dans l'esprit toujours en
interclubs ha jeu dans l'esprit il faut
surtout dire la phrase mythique à la fin
de la partie de toute façon j'ai gagné
cette partie mais il a raté cahier des
fuck là il peut pas appliquer les lieux
8 parce qu'il voulait pas toucher à il
est réfléchi justice n'en a choisi ce
temps pu alors là le 5 nov
un proche 7 matin matin que j'ai 6 66
échec et je vais pas cavalier apsys et
je fais donc eu un fils d'un match si je
te matt quoi ici heures faut prendre que
l'on prend aux cinq ans même je me
débats un petit peu vu des bars ont été
même mieux
je raconte de la gamme heureusement que
tu es là tu sauves le truc quoi c'est
complètement débile ce que j'étais en
train de lire ces lignes
non mais qu'elle prend le set on vous
attends je suis pas sûr ça marche pas
mais je vois pas que je vois pas comment
le faire marcher mais en fait peut-être
qu'ils regardent des trucs gentils si tu
avais le fou si t'avais pas le pur et la
tour où trois corps et d'âme france 7,3
points à 7 tours h trois tours à huit
matches ouais il serait pas un coup de
seattle
ouais mais suffisant retour 3 la veille
5 ouais mais bon vainqueur j'ai envie de
faire marcher un tabou quoi ouais mais
je pense qu'il va faire que les premiers
sets mais je comprends pas à quoi ils
réfléchissent qui me perturbe
tu vois est ce qu'il fait et ce qu'ils
affichaient action prend des six échecs
d'abord genre tu fais fou prend des six
mois je te fait cavalier a aussi séché
et et prend vous prend oui là on
allègera sa machine donc à mon avis il
hésite entre kai prend 1,7 et puis on
précise qu elle mieux on va le savoir
dans quelques secondes
par ailleurs la alors là on comprend pas
ce qui se passe sur re5 là on comprend
pas et on va le savoir encore une fois
dans quelques secondes dont la dame a
choqué si tu prends il te fais tout
reprend 1,8 et hamas en rien pourquoi
pas d'âme aussi dames 6
f4 quelques tu veux faire ça me semble
très bizarre et si je fais quelques
problèmes 6 d'un problème c'est pas
c'est bizarre c'est vraiment bizarre ce
qui est bon ce f4 dam des cinq attaques
le fou menace pas tant v2g fou et quatre
petits coups de bol je suis en tire
encore je crois qu'avec 4 il est
question qu'il fasse il y avait 6 mai le
betis s'affairaient retour s'est vite
très bizarres sont en cours ou faux
trois ans peut-être si là qu'il a il a
finalement craqué failli nous montre
qu'il est humain quoi enfin quand tu
fais quoi sauf aux trois pins et
progressif ou g5 quand même qualité f4
il est bon mais j'aime bien quand même
un bel et bien faire je pensais pas
qu'il allait être obligé de ouais mais
aussi ses obligés de d'un principe tu
vois je pensais pas qu'ils être obligés
d'entrer dans ce prix là mais bon il a
eu le temps d'y réfléchir un an qu'un
bon à l'occasion des 5 sortira quand
même toit mais bon il a gagné tellement
déjà des finales tout ça on dit ça veut
rien que dix secondes avant mais des
victimes ben le truc laurent c'est que
ouais il a un tel avantage psychologique
et machin que c'est pas évident le reste
kf4 marche d'un doute tous et saint-just
et après un coup de fouet fort que j'ai
trois mois soit 180 infatué tours en d2
faire un tour 7 à wil sg de la bienvenue
voilà depuis on passait comme staline et
c'est pas normalement c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle
ok peut-être faire tour d2 et cavaliers
h trois matches faut trois ans peut-être
faute revient aux cahiers des cinq des
quatre voilà c'est chaud il jouait le
feu
bref c'est chaud mais poussé ce 1 ap 5 4
en vue stade je ne vois plus rien ouais
pour tous quelque part
et vas-y que je te refais un échec et je
crois f2 qui arrivent et sailly a tout
organisé
c'est extraordinaire ils ont trouvé
cette manne à ses fantasmes ses fins il
casse tout aurelia patro saint cloud et
4 c'est terminé c'est magnifique et même
et il peut même pousser marge que je te
pousse au cul ras tout est flou et une
peu plus brefs délais non c'était un
essai magnifique laurent et 110 m haies
en ce sens en si peu de temps de
l'arrivée à réorganiser comme ça tout
dire c'est que prend des airs c'est
incroyable c'est face est tellement au
dessus de tout ouais c'est très bref
c'est vraiment c'est très impressionnant
et je commencerai me tiens par beckham
j'allais dire ça à junas dame projet
s'appuie dans l'esprit à fond ouais
m6 a tempo mais il sait qu'ils ont les
positions en avance 1 2 960 ouais mais
là là franchement manu je suis sûr
qu'ils la gardent pas aigri tout je sais
qui les regarde il regarde
la revolver 805 dans le chat qui
écrivent 0,05 plutôt qui écrit c'est
tellement pas mon niveau ses échecs mais
nous non plus ces choix que ce niveau
que d'une seule personne sur la terre
c'est vrai nom mais en fait c'est à dire
tu vois il a joué 20 coups et en fait
voilà au 20e coup à la série des vins
côtes tu vois que finalement en fait
toute cette heure d'harmonie lui après
le plus raciste et un mille francs v7
il a réussi à sécuriser son droit à un
coût et un clou et là le cavalier sur la
colonne des fêtes il a acheté à tout
faire bien senties temps soir du combat
s'est fixé comme quand tu prends l'avion
que tu as un vol le truc qui déconne je
t'en ai même pas rendu compte ya pas une
secousse tu atterris tu dis j'étais en
voiture j'étais en train de quelqu'un
qu'elle transporte j'ai pris tu vois
c'est la nuit sairlines c'est tranquille
quoi tu sais tu sais d'où quoi t'as même
pas besoin de sang secousses sst beau
john thomas mutsch qui écrit un truc tu
réveilles 10 à ses niveaux de la ddt
non c'est autre chose oui c'est juste en
dessous et c'est juste et justement pas
loin mais quand même c'est pas un nom
sur un son qui s'approche du niveau de
batz et ça dans une dizaine d'années
s'il continue à progresser comme ça ça
pourrait être bon après brique et des
promoteurs qui et voilà qu'ils
réussissent à organiser le match mais
bon après on va ressortir vlad de sa
retraite tu vois c'est c'est difficile
c'est comme le retour de zidane de
jordan de faim tu vois tu fus qu'est ce
qui se passe est partie position très
bizarre bon un spécial nouveau massacre
en perspective un spécial mais dans
casse cou s'est terminée comme le savoir
non pour la stratégie joue symétrique 1
il attend les rares voix mais c'est
tellement horrible quand imagine comment
comment great choc nous prendrait à la
part la petite cuillère quoi c'est ça
qui est le plus décourageant là dedans
enfin surtout moi comme dirait fabien
fabien il est sûre toutefois kevin sa
tasse toi plus que moi d'ailleurs pas
encore tu fait illusion lors en soit ça
va ouais mais quoi qu avec magnus wada
grob là j'aurais bien il a joué un jeu
signe un nom mais objectivement ça
arrive à nous faire leurs bonus
tu vois je veux dire en même temps je
refuse pas c'est arrivé une fois
laurence a eu une fois ça m'arrivait
humaine contre josé da mots pareils
grand-chose tournée dernier à prendre
même plus mais je résume josé d'armé
pour de bon coiffeur dit de mérimée +15
pratéens chez pas j'ai paniqué j'ai pas
fait d'amis les mois après il s'y fier
chine que j'ai réussi à perdre à
l'occasion pour rigoler 18 quoi j'ai
commenté ton match luis de manhattan
degroof
ouais là il va se dire d'ailleurs c'est
du poisson il faudra combien de temps
alors qu'ils récupèrent de cette grotte
je crois qu'il ya pas récupéré je pense
que c'est toi la crise est quand même là
je pense à nous faire marrer non pas sur
le coup 1 sur le coup ça fait pas marrer
de sa session non mes chances et a dû
voir la vidéo en plus à la tournée
partout sur internet c'est possible
lui demande il a dû se dire cet abruti
opus il affiche une caisse non mais
quelque part c'était la vengeance par
rapport à la vidéo qu'il a fait avec toi
quoi oui nous devrons forbach frenchman
enfin dégage tu te voir on est français
quoi défendre
bon là il est mal quand même magnus ne
me dis pas l'un vers c'est pas possible
j'ai l'impression qu'il a il a donné il
a donné beaucoup plus rien rémysson mais
à temps et prend des 4000 pages quoi je
pense qu'elle sait 3 enfin remarqué
existants l'air aussi jean serrat wilaya
ces trois ans fait en r oui mais à quel
est ton écran des otages
ouais mais iata tour des quatre à la fin
à la vraie et voulait peut-être là mais
la date on prend 17
ouais c'est probable oui c'est les
saveurs pas ma mère est là il donne la
qualité en fait il est pas trop le choix
je pense est en fait ils adopteront mais
il a depuis à 2 go à une position bons
petits cavaliers en d4 le roi blanc le
roi noir est faible les blanchons mieux
vaut faire mieux mais ils vont perdre
akalé résultat tient magic terrena dans
même si julie joue en différé et en fait
ma nièce a gagné 19 à 9 tu sais que ça
ce point crowd arrive au regard des truc
génial qu'on adore avec femmes c'est
qu'ils ont fui des algorithmes qui te
calcule un speech est championship 2009
sans 1919
ils le font jouer à des ordis et pour
sauver l'équipe c'est ça avec famille on
veut absolument retrouver une partie
bien sûr la chaîne et l'analyser quoi
fabien et arrêtons d'analyser les
parties moderne on va te reprendre
toutes les parties citées bruttin
d'accor d'anf et il en est donc
programmé les ordi pour qu'il joue dans
le style des jeux s'est plus quittés en
finale l'état peut-être incapable en cas
les kin la kiss
du coup avec fabien on est très content
de cette compétition c'est génial c'est
maintenant c'est drôle comme truc c'est
pas mal je sais pas qui a eu l'idée de
faire ça mais je sais pas je crois qu'il
ya du rub in the times alexine en 2004
comme ça tu sais que tu sais que ton
poulain est complètement rires oui je
sais mais bon je savais que ce texte m'a
parlé de la partie je me dis je le
pourrai pas qu'on va bien à partir ont
pu retourner la qualité est il un gros
pions moins bon il bat pour changer à
l'échangé la hâte en quittant la
deuxième chambre où elle va être
compliquée celle là aussi sauf si leurs
notes on arrête le live on ferme tout en
fermeté à temps là en train de récupérer
bon on sait relancer un petit peu on
reste quand même
j'en peux plus mais en plus le pire
c'est que great chose non seulement si
tu compares tus avec le résultat des
autres joueurs il en train de faire
enfin il est bien en avance par rapport
au score de socoa fin mai par rapport au
fait quoi si vous regardez la télé et
que il avait complètement laissé filer
leur plein gré à gré oxo tu vois le
match il n'y a pas trop de suspens
non voilà c'est quand même s'est il est
bien meilleur en béton je ne fais pas
photo donc là il lui pose des petits
problèmes pratiques mais c'est ça l'art
c'est facile quand on fait tomber quatre
et alors ils poussent comme ça qu'il
faut les pousser en même temps le les
pions tu vois tous ensemble quoi il
s'est bloqué le roi je sais pas mais tu
présentes à vouloir vraiment très
bizarre comme ça que je ferai la
technique soviétique la fameuse la
fameuse une légende d'aujourd'hui
finalement non mais il ya une vraie
technique soviétique mais bon
l'institut canalys dietic and on grille
ou kényan en union soviétique de
justesse voix et une justesse allemand
mais bon tu as il n'est pas il est
pareillement subi fin soviétique
soviétique tu vois il est bas c'est plus
ce que c'était un les jeunes n'est pas
si je n'avais chucky la codi hommage à
noter jeunes à le saluer les jeunes et à
34 à quoi tu vois un bon bah tu as fini
la gagne pâques
non mais ok mais si tu es une femme je
pense que le roi henry la catch la
transition qui s'est pas tu mets droit
en f5 j'ai 5 et 6 passes pas ça non
baroin 5 tu passes par web se prend pour
des 4-6 3-6 6-4 6-4
non mais ça à force j'en pouvais plus
quoi moi aussi j'ai perdu la confiance
donc là encore un petit break c'est ça
un micro brakes micro break je reviens
dans pendant dix secondes cette année on
croit en ce moment vas-y vas-y vas-y
prends ton temps
ouais on nous dit pas aussi soviétique
que vous la dévoile à et voilà non c'est
pas aussi solide que là tout ça bon
alors on remet un petit lien sur les
médias sociaux pour voir les bullet ça
quand même être intéressant sait-on
jamais il n'y a que six points d'écart
on partage sa part tout allait on essaye
de faire 750 spectateurs ce soir je sais
pas combien on est mais 750 ce serait
pas mal aller les tontons il ya tonton
laurent aussi avec nous c'est quand même
pas mal d'avoir laurent frayssinet c'est
quand même pas mal
même si 172 l on essaye de faire 750 ce
serait pas mal ce serait pas mal
on est bien on est nombreux c'est un
beau match il ya le bullet on va voir
risque est ce que magnus va de nouveau
passer en mode super saiyan et écraser
great loong en bullet ou est-ce que gris
tchoumba va faire l'effort je suis venu
à lyon par amp et non non et les gens tu
vas y dis ce serait tuer ils te disent
c'est génial de l'avoir en parlant de
toi d'accord et il perdre et que ça
super match bon on aurait aimé que ce
soit un peu plus serré on va pas se
mentir mais ils sont très très content
tu as des gens ni merci laurent decaux
commenté rita d'or coiffe d'accord
génial distincts des jeunes et les plus
sympas du circuit ne connaît pas ils
sont ils ces trésors de quoi enfin là on
n'a pas encore les messages insultants
en dix ans c'est beaucoup mieux de
fabien ou quoi mais ça va arriver
merci de nous avoir sauvés de fabien on
en pouvait plus jouer plus
fabien déjà hier on l'a pas on l'a pas
ratée non mais on n'a pas ce qu'on aime
bien
oui c'est à exactement si on les met pas
en fait on se permettrait pas c'est l'un
vertes ont exactement c'est toujours
comme ça c'est toujours comme ça re est
bon donc à comines à +6 du coup il ya
plus 6
alors c'est quoi ta pronostics en privé
moi je mettrais 9 de magnus mais bon 9,2
m'amuse ouais ouais et de terrebonne
supporters qui croient géant voisin
supporters de l'om c'est moi je suis
pour l'om depuis longtemps je ne suis je
ne suis furent match de fou tu vas pas
quand je les vois quatrième là je me
bats je ne comprends même pas tu vois le
grison qui loue des là qu'ils perdent 3
0 contre le psg était content en fait
dit heureusement je t'ai pas c'est quoi
non mais c'est ça la barre fois en plus
à la fois que j'ai vu un match marseille
psg c'était avec ciani gods
l'ifa j'étais pas avec yannick mais
c'était dans un peu froide et pris 4 0
mais aux drogues ou 5 0 c'était une
horreur d'accord ouais t'as peu mou
c'est à cannes attaque mais bon j'en
pouvais plus bas zetes et non parce que
s'ils prennent le tueur absalon soit pas
marseille près de 4 ou 5 0 tel plan
d'ordre est quand même non tu vois même
cité pour marseille et sa nouvelle
équipe pour commencer la voir tout ça un
peu violent non même si vite après je
sais que j'y pense matata pas tu adores
114 millions en tant que supporters de
great choc 9,2 sinon c'était 1-0 d'accor
north moi je pense que ça à 30 de plus
ils réclament se trouve dur voilà bien
la plus fashion de magnus moins méchant
alors on va pouvoir jouer notre jeu
préféré ou aussi avec fabien on a un
petit jeu comme tous les matches sont
pas serrés on essaye de calcul est
mathématiquement alors je vais mettre le
temps en temps une petite seconde et non
un jour nécessaire mathématiquement à
quel moment tu peux avoir gagné le match
sans toucher à la souris adacore sont
pas le candu qui restent dans le match
en fait il joue quand même temps les
bulles est une demi heure une demi heure
je vais je suis en train de le mettre
sur l'écran pour que les spectateurs et
je tiendrais au courant et on va jouer à
ce jeu là en fait un monde au nez on
essaiera de calcul et tu vois comme au
basket accueille maintenant tu vois je
ne souhaite plus et je j'attends quoi ou
tu peux jouer des coudes et bilan fait
aussi
oui comme ça il ya le talent rajoub et
on devrait avancer le truc mathématiques
et sasha qui faisait avec moi oui oui ça
nous avait énervé mais bon après ouais
d'abord une excuse à parlant c'est qu'on
y avait déjà fait ça n'ont jour où je
crois que c'est ce qu'il a dit dans
l'interview tu vois post matérialisme
en gros si piqué son portefeuille en
mailly quotidien ben c'est un peu
l'histoire de huy non mais à l'échelle
pas sorti à paille a pas longtemps je
leur livre là-dessus c'est un mec qui a
essayé de faire un livre est plus disert
sur l'origine de tous les conflits et en
fait son lit d de son bouquin
en fait tu as un mec qui a commencé un
jour à faire une merde et en tête à tous
les autres qui tu vois enchaîne on
s'excuse on de ce truc là tu vois du
coup c'est lui qui a fait donc moi j'ai
fait ça lui qui a fait ça lui tutu enfin
enfin c'est l'histoire de l'humanité au
final alors c'est vrai j'ai poussé un
peu ce à quoi mais c'est ce que tu dis
c'est qu'avec toi le toit il ya quelques
années mon portefeuille déjà tiens ça me
donne le droit de voler le portefeuille
de tous les gens et ça passe à 57,11 et
c'est intéressant je sais pas ça se
discute pas mais donc la partie il est
pas terrible
c'est ça donc c'est pour ça qu'ils
changent de sujet à chaque fois qui est
diabolique du papa et la partie quand il
est mort mais ils seront c'est un peu la
cerise l'accord qui lie ce faire face au
fait à ces jeux font en des 8es quand
même pas tail dans le fond des 8
dominent de cavalli t5 leur antre oui
c'est ça salah exactement c'est un
concept nom mélanie roy watch this way
il veut mettre le ranger 5
ouais ça fait près dans l'esprit la
chance va faire b6 a été super moi j'ai
cinq tours hlm ont empêché un alto alto
blague d'un v6 pas mal ce que moi je
suis au prix du pion que tu rends qui
échangent temps fou quand même
damas 7 il peut plus faire tout rachat
si peu farouche à hasnon mirror croit g5
damage 4 et je m'affiche ou peut-être
même tour prochain aura prend en charge
et oui oui c'est ce que tu veux et voilà
exactement la même et est emmanchée leur
fou prend b6 après et c'est chaud génial
son truc c'est matt ou quoi non mais
attends c'est pas mal un rush un tour à
chiens damage de systemat batailler pas
matin les deux d'alger 2 je te mena très
oui pas mal pas mal pas mal 1 0 aller
bien vu qu'il n'ya plus que sa faim ça
il ya encore cinq points d'écart mais
c'est pas le massacre un savary sauve
l'honneur incroyable mais attend les
romans taden la fameuse boule gambier
veulent alors à temps parce que j'ai été
déconnecté comme dame
comme toutes les heures un peu quoi
allez-vous pro af c'est debout
le groupe dégage dégage en d4 alepian
centraux contre la pièce était mieux
d'être tout à fait laurent as tu vas
écrire notre homme après ce match
[Rires]
l'année prochaine en équipe de france ça
tu avais fabien bombe à laurent puis je
vous crois aujourd'hui vous mach 4 au
premier des cages à tania pas tout
reprend g7 est où là il est 3 h 1 donc
si on est deux après ça la fout mal
qu'on met là ne me dis pas que great
food a encore bien non je pense pas
parce que comment il sort ses pièces
doit ça ressemble la partie de banyuls
contre maxime a su si oui la variable
sorti comme ça où il a donné d'options
aux activités les anglaises
oui savent qu'on a fait et envoyés vivre
vous l'avez commande vous l'avez
commenté sur la chaîne je couvrais ouais
on l'a fait il ya peu de temps
l'ontarien de sortie date avec à ses
lames sont pas sortis et l'autre se
développe qui voyagent à mach 4 qui
arrive qu'un malgache quatre rois 17
pour g8 enfin tu vois il peut se passer
des trucs assez rapidement mais bon il
ya quand même des pions oui les pions
c'est très chaud il ya la paire de fouet
gritche ou que je le sens pas tant
dessous que ça on bulle est finalement
il en avait un peu peur avant le match
je peux le dire maintenant
et finalement finalement l'art au mental
à ce possible
on n'y croit pas alors on voit pas pour
le moment mais la même feuille le faire
d'après f3 et ont fait un final brême
est de fous et voilà finale ça va quand
fu est deux jours dans la finale et je
vais gratter le pion aux cinq espions de
plus et il fait faire des jets à vos
clients des sites mais ça devrait pas
suffire effectivement il ya beaucoup de
pure on bafoue prend des systèmes
intermédiaires non ouais je pense qu'ils
ont dû le faire en est maintenant il est
ce cahier le fouet aux fraises
finalement après des stages f3 rouaroua
des 4
je te fait le coup du tueur h&m et tour
f
bref un tour eu deux temps le point à 3
et complètement aux fraises en fait
ouais mais attend ainsi lloris a fait
retour g7 tourcoing fc tours g7
maintenant sur la solution des deux je
te prends f cet effet des trois îles
maintenant il va faire tourner cette ton
plan non mais mettons g8 échec ton g7 à
tour eiffe 8,8 bien joué il veut pas
faire la nounou qui va prendre
touré fuite et tourache huit bouts non
car il veut gagner du temps en fait
ah ouais c'est vraiment même en une puce
une et je pourrais le temps devient
tellement jamais tant qu hélas il est
complètement gagné en fait ouais
oui en faire voir de st croix roi aussi
s'il va les mater à l'ancienne gare
non mais surtout il ya maintenant il ya
je crois qu'il prenne un plus ouais et
aux tontons l'auvent effaçait tibétaine
est finie avant goulet est lésé au four
vetcho bois larmont tada arom montana
allez il faut que vous inviter tout le
monde à leur manière sur les réseaux
sociaux faut que vous inviter tout le
monde à voir ce match est peut-être en
train de voir la surprise incroyable
quand la remontée fantastique la
chevauchée chevaucheur de cochon situe à
clash royal tu es une carte un mec qui
est sur un cochon qui attaquent à fond
quoi mais bon impressionnant un green
shoots là sur le début ouais présent
mais quand tu penses là maintenant
laurent a ou trois quatre occasions
trois quatre parties qu'il a perdu il y
aurait il y aurait 11 11 l'at-on point
j'aurais 99.9 d'affoler mais je crois
qu'il va s'énerver au petit maillot de
l'opti le petit je sais pas pourquoi
mais maintenant qu'on l'appelle again
the kid
je crois qu'il va lui faire des cinq là
je pense que ça va mal se passait bien a
pour sacha il a cru que c'était terminé
tu vois il a tellement dominé derniers
matches ont voulu être ici est cru en
toi
il a trop pris la confiance il a trompé
la confiance il faut faire attention et
la croissance
c'est bien et ça craint pour sasha parce
que des fous prend 1,4 tu vois tu peux
pas comment tu sors ton cavaliers b8
ouais y'a pas trop le sortir ton cas ib
vite à ton roi aux fraises en
heureusement le ta ta ta phu de cases
noires qui est qui est magnifique en
russie doit qu'à venir ici et c'est tout
ce que tu as on va pas se mentir même
genre est toujours aux cinq là tu vois
bon c'est pas aimer ps mais rien qui a
aidé cette maintenant épreuve 5
ouais ouais là c'est alors terminé quand
même à temps
pourquoi ce sont là pourquoi se serait
terminée si vite ses patates à 10 km à 4
et prend un quart est allé vous en
france si on prend 1,4 c'est vrai bien
battre on a bien joué lès tours 2 non
même pas normal c'est pas si claire fais
toi
non il est gagnant c'est sûr mais ouais
mais tu en bulle en bulle est tu peux
avoir du dan b2 qui arrive hein tu as tu
peux avoir un truc débile qui t'arrive
dessus mais même si ces miles ou pas à
décaler des cas très bien joué ouais a
très bien joué mais bon ils menacent ces
entreprises prises il va remettre une
tour ans et 8 1
qu'est ce qui s'y dit non et week-end
des 5 et ses 3,5 wemmel kébé c'est ce
qui sauve tout vous des trois t3 et
maryse condé 3 ouais mais c'est pas
grave ou pas et où cinq là ils attaquent
offre tout platel d'un coup pour prendre
ces dégénérés type c'est incroyable et
cela c'est vraiment bon là ça s'est
tarie à 2008 dont ge
mg c'est le tour des huit sous clause
mais c'est déjà défoncé dans l'ouverture
en fait mais c'est des sacrés les 1000
et 2 1
la vitesse d'exécution mais le foot est
roi il a raté un ouais ouais
la spéciale ma news qui avait vu il ya
mathieu qui nous dit qu'ils avaient
calées france et 4 à bon temps avec
tourbe et 8,6 car si dame france et 4
dames 3 5
ok donc c'est un frédéric lucas raté un
truc
ouais mais bon tu t'assures food et non
sur ceux des non juifs de détroit se bat
de caprins c'est kas qui avait dam d'un
machin rêve des bulletins tu vois dans
la position était vraiment pourri avant
mais bon c en est bien sorti mais il
s'est bien défendu
il a raté les deux pôles de complet en
fait sur cette partie elle s'ajouterait
vit une belle est à vienne
les blancs les blancs sont quand même en
avance 1 on va pas sortir je vois tu
étais même pas t'es même pas proche de
jouer f5 que les blancs on gagne jouer
des 4 et compagnie et 4k lien si ce qui
est fait que défendre
c'est pas c'est pas une version
extraordinaire pour pour pour les noirs
mais bon je peux vous mettre
l'évaluation de l'ordi la attends je
vais essayer de remettre l'évaluation de
leurs livres être content mais pas misé
sur les avaient pas mis sur les parties
d'avant parce que comme on est avec
laurent et que tu es quand même un
projet pas envie que les gens aient les
yeux rivés sur sur l'analyse de
l'ordinaire pour les bullet c'est vrai
que c'est pas mal
ouais lario takes et du stockfisch
profondeur 14 donc bon ouais ça peut se
compter en faisant la même cette tour g8
maintenant les élus blanc je sais pas
c'est compliqué ces pollutions et
cavaliers ou 4 il n'a pas vu donc là il
ya un problème sur f2 et maintenant on
souhaite faire ré aux quatre ça va
normalement ça va tout cela pour l'avoir
eu quatre tours g8 d'alger 6 ou être 4 3
3 qui arrive f3 qui arrive c'est vrai
c'est une horreur
mais bon franchement mouvement il ya
encore ça tient encore est étroite a
encore fait fort machin mais bon ouh là
là il en action ouais alors ça c'est ça
c'est une très mauvaise ou est basse a
changé puisque tapis ton idée
stratégique de féret fouet d'or c'est
horrible mais faut prendre trois si la
qualité c'est vraiment avec plaisir
elle est complètement laisseras tu n'as
plus de cavaliers v8
il dégage avec tant que les ibériques
en tout cas il n'existe plus après ça
peut être un conseil stratégique
intéressant gens faire mes propres
pièces comme c'est le concept d'axel
smith exactement il a écrit dans son cas
ça tout l'état toutes les bonnes
références étaient bons non mais tu
essaies tu vas tu fais des progrès
énormes que tu as les méthodes jour
qu'imagine dans deux jours je prends
vite ses coûts et 4,3 temps ferme et ont
poussé un essai très heureux enfin on
était bien bah je te cache pas que
l'ordi est très heureux pour les blancs
ouais ça je m'en doute après un coude et
g5 à un coup de coupe tu as tu prends
une conduite tu vois beaucoup qui
perdaient tous ces genres de coups je
fais en général vite
non mais l'accueil procès sept c'est
bien tu libères le pion c'est pas mal et
puis d'un brevet 6 qui ait à les trouver
leur tour
il est malin toi ça ne peut pas marcher
attendre et s'il gagne cette partie non
mais il va pas gagner a vu ses sept la
haye à 6,7 à oui je tourne et dames 1 il
fait d'un bon ben on est toujours dans
le match et coûtent huit et demi
douzaine mire il reste quand même temps
il reste 15 minutes et il y aura une
partie de 960 donc il faut remonter
trois points en 15 minutes et coûte vu
la physionomie du match et les parties
les loulous et j'en veux dire les
zoulous c est ce qu il a fait voter
c'est concrètes appartement de passer
dix secondes il a passé la famille les
mêmes
non il n'a pas joué même qu'on ait à
jouer des 5 et 6 non mais tu vois le m'a
franchement là posteriori quand tu vois
le scénario le machin le truc tu te dis
que green touch c'est quand même un
sacré morceau parce qu'il est il est
loin sans être paraguay notre maxime un
maxime il est quand même dans le lait
sur dans le top 5 des meilleurs angles
tu vois pour moi le top 5
je sais pas encore loin mais s'écarte
celle des trucs la camorra car jaeckin
et maxime après l'ordre j'en sais rien
tu vois donc c'est numéro un ça c'est
sûr mais après ça c'est sûr et après
entre les quatre autres c'est très dur à
lire parce qu'ils ont tous gagné des
tournois complètement monstrueux sais je
sais pas c'est tu vois ils ont tous à
peu près de la mélo ils ont tous
toujours des résultats monstrueux donc
c'est assez dur à dire ça dépend en fait
de la forme d'une thèse sur les quatre
d'entre eux sont nés moi je vois c'est
une maxime j'ai vu plein blitz où il
finit à 14 sur 15 aient eu d'autres
d'autrefois où il fait ajourner en
revanche on sait pas il finit pas
terrible donc signé une question de
forme à berlin il avait fait une journée
une fille coincée dition et battu manu
cv tout le monde et leurs miles
il que deuxième je me rappelle j'avais
commenté ce truc là en direct c'est le
premier truc que j'ai commenté en
français d'ailleurs il avait égaré deux
points d'avancé reste un truc là préfère
qu'on me dit qu'elle court et j'entends
aussi quoi oui oui un peu toutes mes
coups ça c'est plus que c'était aux vols
vomica et projecteurs mais ça ne marche
pas du tout dans bizarrement leur dis
aime bien qui est étrange et kahlan on
avait commencé à comprendre mais oui en
profondeur 13 est complètement nulle en
fait il vous faut absolument rien parce
que c'est complètement de la merde faut
être trois rois g2 et je te lis phase
iii allait à 5 mais un petit coup de
tournevis l'ex turquie facile
complètement réelle d'un match 7
on va pas prendre la qualité
un petit coup de courage là ça va faire
du bien angers coeur voilà c'est après
c'est normal de continuer à jouer en
bullet mais ouais mais il y croit pas
bref autour des tice voir vraiment bon
ben là en l'occurrence je peux plus
faire tour des sites parce qu'il est
toujours un échec
on sait même pas si con il est là pour
17 maintenant des quatre ça serait pas
mal de abandonné parce que il reste
quand même par des plats de partie op à
quoi ça sert de jouer cette partie
franchement c'est le tilt là ouais bah
ils abondent mais ce qui reste douze
minutes
il ya plus 5 de nouveau ouais ça va être
difficile il ya plus grande erreur il
peut encore se permettre une minute
peut-être
ouais mais ouais ouais mais bon tu voies
d'eau match nul vraiment moi je voyais
tellement au dessus en bus la de carlson
que je me disais bon va finalement
machin perly plus vite mais vu comment
ça se passe en bullet c'est dommage
qu'il ait pas démarré là la section à
moins de moins en moins deux comme
l'année dernière ouais ouais ouais ça va
t il à il a fait un répertoire spécial
pour le but est malin
ouais le even si la garder pour le
bullet jarre il ya deux trois idées ce
cas ils ces trois là tu vois sur a4 a26
calais troyes c'est la vieille idée de
kasparov pour aupic est comme ça tu vois
un truc bien oublié tu vois où
probablement les devants 1-0 problème
mais il faut se souvenir mais enfin
l'arrogance il est quand même pas mal
avec la dame c7 qu'il a réglé la mire il
a peut-être été un peu surpris du niveau
de grip choc aussi un as au sycoscan
voilà c'est terminé
mais après c'est terminé ça paraît
compliqué là il joue beaucoup mieux et
la position est pourri en fait j'utilise
tournoi il a pour moi et une noix
structure fou un fou de cases noires qui
joue pas terrible et qui joue pas trop
avec html5 bien gérér devisy vise et
c'est qu'apple a fait refaire 1,5
il fait ses 4 alors parce que manu
katché qui le truc way sur des cinq
avocats voulaient alors et les deux il y
aura kébé 2
[Musique]
mais là où pire je te refile le pion tu
vois tu le sais déjà que les sacs au bon
moment j'ai simplement maintenant je
vais me faire g5 h5 g4 et non la et
accroître et qu'il ait mis autant les 20
secondes d'avancé mais gris choo qui
pourra s'en vouloir quand même d'avoir
raté autant de
d'opportunités dans l'est dans les 5
plus d'eux surtout un ouais mais tu vois
le scénario du match aurait peut-être
été différent et et les deux ils veulent
mater attention matin qui va faire
revenir pour ca qu avait focalisé 3 bon
évidemment ça c'est les choses qu'ils
voient tous les deux ont même pas un
dixième de seconde donc la qualification
terminé le cavaliere 5 et est enfermé
rouages 7 g 6 c'est plus de cavaillé il
a troublé de fer g3 un moment ça soit
très moche c'est mort à noter un que si
vous regardez l'évolution ordinateur en
fait aller bien pour y semer gestion de
l'ordinateur il ne comprend absolument
rien moi j'ai fait ça qu'il faut faire
j'ai 3 puis on prend kg 2 la course
risque de mal se passer là quand même un
truc c'est que c'est lui qui prend c'est
lui qui rasent ils vont arriver à
d'année en même temps mais manu sera les
plans plus il peut pas les chèques et
surtout il va avoir d'amd 5 ou dam des
quatre prochains échanges les dames il
voilà c'est terminé c'est fini là pour
le coup il reste neuf minutes à jouer il
ya six points de retard il faudrait
gagner cinq parties en huit minutes 50
ça me paraît impossible laurent ouais je
suis d'accord une petite vente des
changes
échec aussi ses parties de malgus
contraire monast restants y suivent même
ambulante 1 et se permettent d c'est
exactement la partie mais ont pu l'être
s'ils connaissent mieux la théorie que
moi a laissé le parti qui a déjà joué
l'autre à 10 près de bon ok c'est pas
grand chose pour les blancs mais
normalement c'est un peu plus agréable
pas tellement en tout cas pas c'est
c'est bourré pourquoi il peut pas
prendre de but en 17 mois il peut un
bond de 8 1 3 6 1 h2o est obligé à wii
fit à damas six francs h2 tient la tour
en russie c'est bien placé mais sur
damas est il ya peut-être un nul non
rien objet de la jouer aux marques
où et comment
comment tu la sauvetat dame pour le coup
je crois que deux choix que j'ai un gros
problème en fait il n'y a peut-être joué
des cinq amis à ouvrir les sacs bataille
le faire chez ffg prend m6 et du coup
sûr c'est sûr des cinq longs à pousser
sans quoi exactement tout reprendre et
tout ça ça n'a fait tour à 8 alors dit
n'a pas du tout aimé tout reprend 1,8 je
sais pas apprécié la juste ou pas mais
n'a pas du tout aimé
je pense gf38 ou d'apprendre vite
il appelle mes tours a vite pour les
noirs je pense qu'ils voulaient faire
mais je pense je pense que gm ne voyait
pas comment sur textes tour à tour pour
la dame aux deux des twin twin cup
oui mais en fait tu aurais le pion f6 et
puis arrive cette et l'autre n'aurait
pas de fou il manquerait un cavalier qui
lui manquerait un truc ouais bon c'est
quand même c'est quand même gagné oui
c'est moins gagnant et moi gagnants ex
on va dire ça comme ça
non non mais c'est hélas encore aider
devient joueur sait pas si cette
position avec l'adam qui voient en
bullet
si j'avais à la défendre et prendre
confiance
meiway les maintenant les quais les
cavaliers qui se protège c'est pas mal
car il couvre beaucoup de cases ouais
ouais
écoute est offert tous rêvent cette
attention idée quand il les joue en fait
un nom mais monstrueux et pour vous
c'est miki mieux non adams et 2 je
n'arrive pas à teva lui et ça c'est trop
ça va trop vite en fait oui peuvent se
faire sur qui les prendra me prend au
caté d'un machin après c'est pas
possible
ils veulent mater les g1 hormis garrigue
il n'y avait pas ça non mais je suis
curieux du gpra f6 quand même un
peut-être que il est maintenant il joue
pour gagner ou pas mais qui est sis le
roi est complètement 1
voilà où le roi sort plus le noyau
fraises mais bon il doit avoir des père
péter adam des cinq échecs mais
milliards à foot et 6 d'un point f2
c'est incroyable et il arrive à lui
faire des baptêmes des dames 6 m6 ou
quelle gare ou quelle gaffe horrible
ouais il remonte à l'est vraiment à ça
c'est fait il ya il y à vraiment dans un
poisson
il remonte à moissac non mais tu vas
enfin pas alors c'est pas une
humiliation du tout au final à 19,2 et
moi non plus ça que tu vois on n'était
pas aux pronostics ont été on est aux
fraises nouveau procès mais on suppose
que tu sois sont les sassou monde a
compris qu'on était aux fraises totale
quoi ouais pas que sur les pronostics un
d'ailleurs sur sur à peu près tout et je
l'avais compris comme ça aouita et tout
de suite à ta est tout de suite bien
compris qu'on était ouais quand on était
aux fraises un relais seront totalement
les vrais fraises
il va rien n'avance mon amour de